[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hello à tous on est parti pour ce steam
du tata style en compagnie de Laurent
Freyssinet aujourd'hui c'est l'invité
salut à toi Laurent salut à tous salut
Kevin salut à tous alors je suis
évidemment très heureux d'être ici ça
c'était la première chose que je tenais
à dire et la deuxième chose que je
tenais à dire je ne suis rien
responsable du retard qui a eu un petit
un petit quoi technique on s'en excuse
je crois mon cher Kevin on s'en excuse
et je peux vous assurer que moi non plus
je suis pas responsable c'est toujours
un petit peu ça alors en personnage dans
ces cas-là
sur le dos c'est incroyable c'est toi
qui faut assumer moi j'avais tout
paramétré on le sait bien et après il y
a eu vous savez il y a des grands ponts
au niveau de Chess.com et nous on est
que commentateurs Laurent du coup voilà
on fait face à l'organisation qu'on nous
propose et en tout cas là ça va être
vraiment qualitatif parce que j'ai rien
à faire au niveau technique c'est comme
dans un rêve finalement Laurent pour moi
aujourd'hui alors que je pensais être
soumis à une pression psychologique très
importante en devant assurer la
technique en tout cas je suis très
content de faire ce stream avec toi
Laurent ça faisait un petit moment qu'on
s'est pas vu c'est toujours un petit peu
en coup de vent et on va voir l'occasion
ben de commenter de sacré parti et c'est
vrai que tu es un intervenant privilégié
puisque tu es secondant du champion du
monde de Blitz et de rapide Magnus
Carsen exception du monde puisqu'il
redonne son titre
permet de te corriger encore une fois
disant mais ça va pas arrêter
je suis désolé Kevin mais je vais pas
être parti de pêche après mais bon il
est champion du monde de parti classique
jusqu'en jusqu'au 30 avril prochain
jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un gagne le match
je suis désolé mais il a déjà il a déjà
vu dans notre cœur Laurent comme tu le
sais et d'ailleurs Laurent tu as suivi
Magnus lors des cinq derniers
championnats du monde c'est ce que tu me
disais tout à l'heure
et toi ça te fait quoi qu'il est
qu'il a arrêté cette là
alors ouais les cinq dernières en fait
c'est les 5 qu'il a joué donc j'ai été
c'est une vraie fierté de l'avoir
accompagné
pendant ces 5 matchs pas
forcément nécessairement que j'ai été je
sens pas tu vois si j'avais pas été là
je pense qu'il aurait certainement gagné
quand même mais le fait qu'il m'ait
choisi et qui me fasse confiance pendant
toutes ces années finalement le premier
match était en 2013 on est quand même en
2023 alors effectivement quand il a
annoncé quand il est annoncé son arrêt
bah tu sais c'est
petite mort quoi tu vois un truc qui
s'arrête donc forcément ça fait quelque
chose surtout que moi j'étais convaincu
que ça fait ça fait plusieurs fois qu'il
en parle d'arrêter ses matchs qui n'aime
pas le format il y a beaucoup de stress
qui prend pas de qui prend pas de
plaisir en fait dans ces matchs parce
qu'il y a énormément de préparation
il y a énormément d'attention et donc au
final ça fait trop de stress et assez
peu de plaisir mais bon moi je me disais
oui bah cause toujours toujours en
attendant il joue et ça va continuer et
en fait non ça n'a pas continué donc
voilà c'est sa décision qui est
éminemment respectable je crois qu'il
faut si on sait pas si euh
du monde on peut pas savoir exactement
ce que c'est la gagner 5 il avait un
adversaire qu'il a déjà battu
et franchement si on regarde avec tout
le respect dû à des premiers chiffres
mais si on regarde les résultats des dix
dernières années et le résultat dernier
match et les classements hello bon ben
je crois qu'il y a pas photo entre
Yannick et Magnus Carson est-ce que tu
te souviens est-ce que tu peux me citer
un tournoi à parler candidats que il y a
des pommiers à gagner
non je sais juste que dans la base il a
gagné quand il était tout jeune contre
Magnus voilà ce cheval du monde voilà
mais c'est voilà donc
c'est quelqu'un qui a jamais gagné le
Norway de chess
beaucoup moins régulier il c'est un
joueur extraordinaire mais par rapport à
Magnus de toute façon c'est Magnus bon
comme on disait dans le chat c'était le
meilleur joueur de tous les temps en
terme de régularité de performance
et dans l'air moderne être incontesté
comme il l'est et c'est c'est quand même
extrêmement difficile ouais et donc
voilà je comprends ce manque de
motivation et c'est ce qu'il avait dit
il voulait jouer un joueur de la
nouvelle génération toute façon tous ces
joueurs exceptionnels comme Kasparov
carpov ou Magnus ils se font moi ça fait
ça fait 10 ans que je le dis ils se font
tous détrôner par la nouvelle génération
justement ça n'existe pas en fait il
battent leur génération tu vois ils ont
ils ont un avantage non seulement ils
sont plus forts mais il y a un avantage
psychologique à mon avis
qui est où il y a pas grand chose à
faire alors certains me diront qu'on ne
s'est pas passé loin c'est vrai mais
globalement je crois que ce genre de
grand champion il perdent contre la
génération suivante et voilà on avait
les raisins qui auraient pu en karaté
ces candidats mais c'est vrai que un
match contre été
accepté déjà par Magnus et très très
intéressant évidemment oui on en profite
pour dire salut à tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent je sais pas si tout le monde
y avait beaucoup beaucoup de monde on a
vu Néandertal qui arrive j'ai vu Joakim
wama de fianketo X Cyril
buginner etc il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
monde dans le chat merci pour tous vos
petits mots sympas
et c'est vrai qu'on posera et vous
pourrez poser toutes vos questions à
Laurent concernant Magnus c'est vraiment
intéressant d'avoir on a on a beaucoup
de questions et d'ailleurs peut-être
qu'un jour Magnus il n'exclut pas de
revenir d'ailleurs Laurent il a pas dit
il a pas dit que c'était non pour pour
la vie exactement c'est une pause tout à
fait tout à fait vous pouvez poser
toutes les questions que vous voulez à
Kevin ou à moi autant il fait alors déjà
je vais peut-être expliquer rapidement à
présent ici qui peut être étrange pour
certains
d'autres à d'autres stream et c'est
suite donc évidemment il y a eu les
grandes news c'est cette fusion entre
euh
cheescom et chaise 24 non et play Magnus
pardon enfin ce sera fusion je sais pas
comment on l'appelle je sais pas faut
rachat plutôt rachat est donc voilà tu
avais fait des vidéos d'ailleurs pour
pour chaise 24 fr exactement tu avais
participé et donc voilà donc l'idée
c'est de rapprocher un petit peu tout ça
et pour l'instant en tout cas voilà de
de sortir le meilleur avec plus de
contenu globalement évidemment il y a
beaucoup de discussions en cours rien
n'est complètement arrêté mais je pense
qu'il y aura des bonnes surprises
très rapidement en tout cas ça donne un
groupe surpuissant et du coup il y a des
belles choses à faire au niveau des
échecs d'ailleurs les serveurs chelsecom
commence à patiner parce que il y a
énormément de monde ce qui est très bon
signe et d'ailleurs depuis aujourd'hui
ça semble régler j'espère que pour tout
le weekend on sera tranquille de ce
côté-là mais c'est plutôt une bonne
chose pour les échecs en général et les
échecs en général évidemment les échecs
en français évidemment que c'est une
très très bonne nouvelle et voilà on est
accueilli franchement le le
rachat se passe très bien se passe très
bien les équipes sont intégrés tu vois
différents niveaux enfin en tout cas il
y a une tentative pour ceux qui veulent
bien
participer et continuer continuer à
l'aventure donc ça c'est c'est très très
appréciable et j'en profite pour
remercier tous les gens de chaise.com
avec qui j'ai discuté qui était vraiment
vraiment ouvert tu vois tu sens des gens
voilà ils sont là et on va trouver des
choses à faire on a plus de choses à
faire voilà on veut se développer et on
veut faire des choses pour pour les
joueurs d'échec et donc tout le monde
est très positif c'est ça c'est ça qui
est qui est sympa on va on va parler
chèque peut-être un peu ouais tu sais
Laurent en début de partie souvent perso
donc ça va glorant on va s'y coller et
ça va être ça va être très très sympa
j'espère bien
et un petit bug mais on est on est
revenu après ça
voilà salut à tous et à toutes
on peut la chambre la productrice parce
que elle parle pas français donc ça
c'est bien la saloperie tu vois on peut
dire des [ __ ]
préférés tu vois c'est la lâcheté c'est
l'acheter qui me caractérise donc voilà
j'ai bien vu ça en début de stream j'ai
bien vu ça
c'est ça [ __ ]
enfin bon tu vois je suis je suis très
bon pour ça et merci Salut stuff merci
je vois qu'il est passé nous faire un
petit coucou on a parlé de toi on t'a
remercié pour le gros boulot était passé
nous faire un petit coucou J'espère que
tu vas bien profiter de ton week-end de
repos
du colorant tu voulais parler un petit
peu échec ouais parce que c'est
intéressant il est sérieux ça il est
sérieux mais parce que Wesley tu vois tu
dis les débuts de partir on y va
doucement mais alors justement on laisse
les sauts bon super joueur
extraordinaire très très bon en calcul
très bonne technique juste le petit
défaut à mon avis qu'il a depuis toutes
ces années que je vois
il est trop un moment il fera pas ses
chances quoi c'est à dire que il va il
va jouer le petit coup sûr il va pas
prendre assez de risques alors qu'il
pourrait faire il pourrait faire mieux
pour moi il a la carrure d'un d'un
candidat au titre mondial j'ai juste
conduite
deux fois et en deux ouais c'est un
super à l'époque c'était vraiment j'ai
joué un des plus forts au coco cette
année c'est très fort aussi mais
beaucoup de 2007 et il y avait notamment
en 2011 j'ai perdu avec les Blancs
montrer un petit peu ce qui s'est passé
donc c'est très classique
E3 et la première petite surprise c'est
5 petit rock et le coup complètement
standard d'abord
j'avais travaillé ça pour lui
à ce moment-là qui avait lieu de ok un
coup ici il y a plein de coups il y a
des trois qui est possible cavalier F3
et aussi une option donc c'est ça qu'on
les fait normalement sur les coûts
marginaux des blancs là c'était standard
3 donc cavalier 2 bon on va avoir une
idée de A3 exactement et c'est de
prendre cette paire de fou et là il joue
très rapidement des cinq D5 alors que le
coût normal ici je vais te le montrer
c'est puis on prend des quatre
et sur A3 tu reviens en recette avec le
fou bien sûr ça a l'air beaucoup plus
logique de j'aime bien garder les fous
quoi ouais on a envie de garder le fou
et donc dessiner ce en fait ne crée pas
cette case de repli pour le fou donc
c'est très intéressant tout de suite et
à mon avis alors je sais pas s'il y a
des gens qui ont des qui ont des bases
de données parfois je fais mais là
de voir si c'est à mon avis c'est
quelque chose déjà d'assez rare tu vois
bien sûr ça allait enfin moi je ne
connais pas et j'ai envie de jouer à
trois directs qui était Matic maintenant
bah on imagine bien que Magnus il a
envie de jouer ça aussi qui réfléchit
déjà à ce moment là aux implications de
ce coup Laurent mais à trois tu as envie
de le jouer non ouais A3 donc bon il y a
deux options pour pour les Noirs il y a
soit x 5 mais à ce moment-là il faut
qu'elle le décès c'est ça exactement
soit
j'adore bouger les pièces ok
on fait les deux on fait les deux si tu
veux Laurent
on peut calculer un petit peu à la vague
après on
aveugle tu crois que les gens ils
suivent à l'aveugle un petit peu un
petit peu je mets des flèches et tout ça
on est c'est du semi aveugle c'est ce
que j'appelle de l'aveugle assistée
il fait de bosser un peu les gens mais
regarde puis en français 4 ça c'est
intéressant tu vois ça c'est une
critique il est en train une des lignes
critiques il est en train de calcul dans
ma 4 échec qui a l'air de gagner
5 après tout ça
qui va j'avais peur à cause de cavalier
5 j'ai l'impression que c'était perdu je
voulais montrer dans ma 4e
B5 ici ah non mais c'est bien en passant
ouais
ça ça a l'air trop dangereux je suis
d'accord avec toi mais bon c'est à
calculer quand même tout à fait oh il y
a quand même franchement tout ça je suis
d'accord c'est c'est un peu trop
dangereux mais tu vois c'est
l'échauffement
donc à trois fois cinq et peut-être
possible en fait oui oui c'est rigolo
ouais
donc c'est peut-être ça l'idée de Wesley
je sais pas ça va être intéressant de
voir et il y a une crise tu vois assez
prendre du coup et après pendant c'est
assez proche c'est prendre peut-être et
en fait il a je crois je crois qu'on le
voit sur les sur l'écran et on voit à
trois fous prends ces trois qui a été
j'ai vu reprendre une pièce ok donc du
coup en tout cas ces positions là c'est
hyper intéressant pour les joueurs
amateurs il y a des tensions centrales
de multiples tension et il faut chercher
à les arbitrer et essayer de trouver la
structure qui nous favorise le plus et
il faut se poser une autre question
l'obtention qu'il y a c'est beaucoup à
gérer pour tous les joueurs regardez ce
bordel ambiant et il faut prendre la
meilleure décision stratégique donc Manu
ça c'est légitimement ok il a joué A3
bah proposer une question au fou
regardez X5 qui était intéressant avec
Laurent
et wester a prévu de craquer la paire de
fou sans doute pour obtenir un pion
isolé Laurent tout à fait c'est ça ok
c'est ça déjà été joué en fait oui moi
je l'avais regardé cette position mais
avec un autre ordre de coupe et comme tu
le dis ouais il y a cette tension il
faut prendre des bonnes décisions mais
ça peut aussi se liquider en tu cliques
des yeux il y a plus on prend des quatre
puis on prend des 5 il y a tout qui est
liquidé il y a tout qui est symétrique
et c'est la partie est terminée en fait
donc faut faire très attention à ça
aussi donc il fait c'est prendre des
quatre ici Wesley et sur eux prend des
quatre c'est quasiment certain qu'il va
faire pion prend C4 et créer ce pion
isolé
et pour le volume de son si j'avais tout
réglé par moi-même avant là comme je
gère pas le stream route je pourrais pas
faire grand chose si vraiment c'est
gênant si vous voyez des variations de
dans nos sons vous nous dites et on fera
un petit message à la technique pour
qu'ils pour qu'il gère ça
voilà donc apparemment fait un gâteau tu
me dis qu'on entend pas de bureau faire
boum non pas de bureau qui font boum
boum voilà
donc c'est prendre à 4 alors
est-ce que tu dois me prendre des cartes
Laurent pour garder la structure et ne
pas avoir d'option isolé vous voyez que
après on prend des cartes il y aura un
moment les idées des Français 4 pour
isoler le pion
est-ce qu'on peut faire dames prends des
cartes qui paraît logique pour laisser
les cases noires ouvertes et pourquoi
pas un jour mettre le fond B2 le fait
que manus réfléchit ici il prouve que
d’apprendre les quatre et pas et pas
ridicule et qu'il l'envisage alors
est-ce qu'il a envisagé longtemps j'ai
l'impression que les gens parce que il a
joué il a joué il a joué parce que je
pensais qu'il était
quatre ou cinq
on peut jouer tranquillement sur donc ok
donc il l'a regardé vite fait et Wesley
directement parce que là il doit y avoir
des risques de C5 blanc pour conserver
la structure et du coup il y a il y a
des Français 4 qui a été joué tout de
suite bon ça a du sens je mets je mets
un petit mot à notre à notre sympathique
et compétente productrice bien sûr on va
voir on va voir gay on va parce que
guéri Abdou santorov c'est quand même la
grosse partie du jour niveau classement
en tout cas exactement et du coup est-ce
que tu le demandes est-ce que tu sais
bien que du coup il faut qu'on le
demande est-ce que tu veux que je mette
le petit mot ou vous voyez comment ça
marche c'est différent on a une régie
voilà en tout cas ce que tu es réactif
Laurent alors et qu'est-ce que tu as
pensé mais qu'est-ce que tu crois tu
sais je suis pas je peux non alors chien
vous dire un petit un petit secret c'est
que Laurent vient de découvrir discorde
aujourd'hui non c'est pas vrai si si
c'est vrai
ton pseudo il existe depuis quand
2019 d'accord ok parce que
tu as mis du temps à me le donner ton
pseudo hein tu l'avais un petit peu
alors je vais t'expliquer je vais te
voilà je vais donner aux gens ça va
peut-être plaire aux gens la la version
officielle je n'avais pas de discord
chaise 24 français la vraie version la
vérité que la vérité Jason 4 français a
été créé moi qui suis moderne j'ai dit
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce que c'est
les moyennes communication modernes on
m'a dit discord je dis extraordinaire
vas-y donc à l'époque c'était maritime
c'est-à-dire c'est une crème discorde et
du coup et j'ai créé un pseudo pour
aller voir du coup ça a pas du tout
marché cette histoire de discorde et du
coup j'ai désinstallé discord de mon
ordi et j'y suis plus jamais allé
pendant les deux dernières années donc
voilà donc quand tu m'as demandé mon
pseudo discord
j'étais pas j'étais pas au fait j'ai dû
réinstaller discord enfin bon bref
c'était tout autre truc mais je te
félicite Laurent pour la montée en
compétences sur discord non mais c'est
bien au moins vous voyez Laurent un pas
de langue de bois on peut lui poser
toutes les questions je sais que vous
avez plein de questions tout à l'heure
j'ai vu une question de de Joakim
Muhamad aussi qui nous demandait tiens
Laurent salut pourquoi les raisins
il fait plus trop de parties lente en ce
moment est-ce que tu as des infos
spécifiques ou pas
alors en l'occurrence
des parties longues il avait pas trop
l'occasion d'en faire ce qui était plus
étrange c'est qu'il aille pas au
championnat du monde rapides il avait
l'occasion ici mais on se rappelle il y
a eu cette déclaration toute façon de
l'organisateur à l'organisateur a
répondu officiellement je sais pas si tu
te souviens il y avait eu un problème de
la remise des prix non il faisait le
match je vais partager pendant qu'il
était encore en train de jouer il y
avait eu tout un problème il s'était
excusé mais du coup l'année d'après
aller-retza avait demandé apparemment
plus d'argent bien sûr selon le
réalisateur je ne sais pas qu'est la
version d'Ali resa bon il y a pas de
raison de pas le croire l'organisateur
et du coup je crois qu'il s'en sont
restés un peu là les relations sont un
peu fraîches tu vois
c'est ce que je pense en tout cas et
donc effectivement si tu auras des
droits de partie longue parce qu'il a
joué à Saint-Louis en fait il y avait
pas tellement d'occasions de jouer
depuis depuis le mois de août septembre
il y a pas tellement de tournois de
parties longues quand il y a pas les
quand il y a pas les Grands Prix ah les
Grands Prix n'existe plus mais là cette
année il va jouer
la Coupe du monde il va jouer le grand
gesto il va jouer aussi qu'est-ce qu'il
y a comme moyen pour se qualifier il y a
ce grand open là qui était l'Open de
l'île de Man je sais pas où il aura lieu
mais le ce grand Suisse qu'il avait
gagné l'année d'avant pour essayer de se
qualifier au candidats donc il a quand
même pas mal de Tours à jouer et un
objectif assez clair c'est de se
qualifier comme comme un verre dans
notre notre ami mvl qui va essayer de se
qualifier pour les candidats bien sûr
une urgence pour mvl qui est peut-être
il reste allé un ou deux cycles
exactement et d'ailleurs tu nous alors
on a tous les jours les mêmes questions
pourquoi les raisins n'est pas là donc
qui a répondu on y arrive on y avait
répondu comme toi avec avec Souf parce
que cette histoire vous connaissez bien
mvl on a parlé pourquoi il n'est pas là
déjà il fallait être invité par
l'organisation et d'autre part c'est pas
le tournoi qu'il préfère
et on nous demande tous les jours alors
vous savez qui est le second dent de mvl
qu'elle va être son équipe etc donc nous
on ne sait pas colorant est-ce que tu as
des infos j'ai une rumeur la rumeur
est-ce que tu as le droit de la même
chose
aujourd'hui Laurent
non mais là je peux pas là je peux pas
et alors tu peux nous dire d'où tu tiens
la rumeur au moins
d'une source de quelqu'un c'est ce que
j'ai dit déjà sur le sur le sur la vidéo
de chaise 24h de quelqu'un de plus fort
que moi ah d'accord ok deuxième indice
de plus que moi ok
selon le classement hello moi je suis
pas peut-être que je suis pas
complètement d'accord mais bon le
classement est long malheureusement tu
sais d'accord il est quand même assez
impitoyable et donc voilà tu peux pas
dire que tu es plus fort que un joueur
de 1700 par exemple on peut le dire mais
personne te prend sérieux pour le coup
c'est vrai que tu pourrais au moins nous
inventer un petit quelque chose comme le
dit au chat bah tu tu nous inventes
à manger au public quoi
aussi je n'aime pas mentir donc je ne le
ferai pas je ne ferai pas maintenant
donc voilà bon voilà pour le la petite
histoire donc Ali Raisa ouais ben allez
raisin quand même il faut faut pas faut
se souvenir il simplement il va sur ses
20 ans là il a même pas il a même pas
très très jeune ça va quand même être
ouais c'est extraordinaire ce qui fait
parce que là on voit d'où ça Torah enfin
je sais pas ce que tu en penses de cette
offre mais je suppose que tu étais comme
moi tu es sous le charme oui ça se
trouve c'est son joueur c'est son
poulain depuis un moment donc il arrête
pas de me parler de la torof
du coup il m'a coûté cher déjà ça
t'auras mais oui c'est c'est une vraie
star une vraie star très sérieux en plus
quand on quand on y réfléchit bah d'où
ça torof il y a à peu près le même âge
que les raisins mais même même en
prenant compte de ce tournoi même si
gagne ce tournoi il sera toujours en
retard par rapport à Liège donc c'est
quand même impressionnant de voir
l'avance car les raisins sur tous ces
jeunes prodiges
praguech
gamer même gamer moi gamer
m'impressionne beaucoup là il a pas trop
de points mais il est très très fort
Clément oui bah en fait il m'a coûté
aussi des points parce que en fait le
poulain de souffle c'est Abdou sa torof
et moi j'ai choisi quelle heure pour ce
tournoi suite à ces très bonne perf dans
les tournois récents rapides et et Blitz
au championnat du monde et en fait Kemer
oui il a pas eu trop de aussi dans son
il aurait pu gagner quelque part au
moins deux et
au final bon ça ça tourne pas trop en
serveur mais bon il montre qu'il est en
train de s'installer parmi les lits même
si réalise un résultat modeste par
rapport à ce qu'il à ce qu'il manque
quoi
j'aime bien tu sais ah c'est marrant moi
qui aime pas
moi qui d'habitude tu vois
et du coup ouais on va regarder guéri
alors guéri il a fait dans ce tournoi il
a il a fait du guéri extrêmement bien
préparé donc avec les Blancs il a mis
une grosse pression il a quand même
placé deux trois prépas assez énormes il
avait position quasi gagnantes après
l'ouverture ce qui est très très rare
maintenant de nos jours quand tu
regardes c'est très dur de faire un
écart dans les ouvertures il y a que
guéri qui arrive et les Noirs aucun
problème il a pris sa chance contre Ding
contre Ding il a des problèmes quand
même mais voilà il fait du guéri plus 3
un vaincu un petit un brin de réussite
parce que sa partie conding a été quand
même pas facile mais quand même très
très impressionnant donc là aussi
l'ouverture va être très
va réussir à s'en sortir bien sûr et
juste un instant pour pour revenir
rapidement sur sur la position de
Carlson avant qu'on passe chez
Guéry tu peux nous dire Laurence que tu
penses de cette position où il y a une
pièce d'échanger une pièce mineure le
foot casse noir donc toi tu dois être
spécialiste de ce type de position dans
le sens champion isolé c'est standard il
y a une pièce mineure d'échanger c'est
fou contre cavalier est-ce que tu peux
nous donner les implications ou alors ça
dépend des positions ce que tu peux nous
en dire plus on t'a pas forcément écrit
de livres sur le plan isolé mais alors
mais alors bizarrement Kevin tu vois tu
me surestines ce qui est assez rare chez
toi
tu me déçois dès le début du stream
alors ouais mais alors il y a des pions
désolé j'en ai eu très très rarement
alors les implications les implications
c'est si que j'arrive à sortir toutes
mes pièces avec avec les avec les avec
les Noirs si j'arrive à jouer fou mais
c'est une cavalier 7 et te mettre un
truc en dessin mais je vais être bien
voilà
l'idée c'est quand même d'ouvrir la
position ah ouais mais c'est super et
bah dis donc regarde ça ben oui
et des gros avancées donc on peut dire
du coup si je joue deux coups si je joue
de coussins je tourne vas-y toi c'est à
fois donc tu fais vas-y
1 x 2 cavaliers 7 tu mets un truc en
dessin les noirs sont mieux
limite je prends les Noirs en tout cas
donc à mon avis c'est le seul coup mais
le problème c'est quoi se les connaît le
seul coup candidat en fait ici c'est 4
dessins et après 50
qu'est-ce que tu fais d'autre
normalement le pion isolé avec les Noirs
donc on a un pion isolé face à nous on
se développe on le bloque et on le
presse et avec les blancs comme nous dit
Laurent faut jouer très dynamique sinon
le combat va s'installer durablement on
aura notre pion isolé on va se le faire
taper donc soit faut lancer une grosse
attaque à l'aile roi mais là c'est
illusoire de le faire pour l'instant
donc nos pièces sont pas encore bien
placées sur celui-là
normalement d'ailleurs le fait
d'échanger une pièce mineure c'est pas
une bonne nouvelle pour les blancs parce
que on n'a pas envie d'échanger les
pièces pour aller sur une finale avec
notre pays isolée maintenant on a quand
même récupéré le foot case noire donc on
pourrait éventuellement travailler les
cases noires donc des 5 auraient encore
plus de sens dans cette position pour
ouvrir est-ce que ça sera suffisant
normalement ce qu'on peut dire aussi
Laurent c'est que dès que le coup B6 est
joué normalement c'est là qu'on joue des
cinq donc ça c'est exactement
et je vois pas trop alors on peut le
préparer peut-être on a encore un coup
pour le préparer
ce décape des 5 par exemple si je fais x
si tu fais fou B7 parce que le problème
c'est si je veux si je le prépare avec
tout un qui a l'air logique attends je
vais montrer la B6 au lieu de x 2
7 D5 et là il y a un problème tactique
c'est cavalier à 5 touche le fou et
touche le pion donc là je vais perdre un
pion donc c'est pour ça que je fais X à
deux d'abord et sur fou B7 je fais des 5
et c'est vrai que mon fou du coup il est
plus attaqué là peut-être les blancs
sont un peu mieux je sais pas c'est à
calculer mais avec wati qui joue aussi
vite c'est quand même ça me fait un
petit peu peur ça fait un petit peu peur
et ouais il fait pas de cadeau et sur
cavaliers 5 peut-être Laurent le coup
pénible
je suppose oui cavalier cette fougères 5
je le vois pas trop de cou d'ailleurs
c'est marrant petit coup froid de un
vous voyez hop de préparation pour
mettre des sacs en place alors que à
titre perso l'orange avait vraiment
envie de faire des sacs en un coup tu
vois sans prendre de précaution
particulière 2 x 2 c'est peut-être un
coup malin mais peut-être pas aussi
ouais
faut pas chercher mais il y a 14h bah tu
sais en Bretagne nous on y va alors on
est beaucoup plus provincial notre
approche du jeu quoi c'est ça c'est
caractérise
faut que tu regardes sinon c'est vrai
que
oui
faut voir faut voir faut voir je suis
pas dans un bar parisien là je j'oublie
à chaque fois tu vois dans ce bar
parisien tu fais des blagues sur les
promotions ça fait marrer tout le monde
tout le monde est content tu vois
là non
je voulais juste faire un petit point
j'ai oublié de de compléter la réponse
sur Maxime qui jouait pas tu l'as dit
enfin justement et je veux pas avec
kenzel on sait pas s'il est invité mais
peut-être qu'il a été invité et aussi il
faut savoir avec quand vous avez pour
leur pratiquer c'est quand même très
très spécial c'est très heureux
apparemment il pleut il y a du vent il
fait froid il y a rien à faire sur place
c'est un truc particulier c'est une
expérience particulière avec et en
général d'ailleurs il y a pas de juste
milieu
c'est-à-dire soit les gens adorent soit
les gens détestent c'est jamais oui bon
ça va ça passe non c'est c'est pas du
tout comme ça bon à titre personnel je
suis un peu comme Maxime sur sur ce
point là je vais lâcher d'infos je suis
pas hyper fan de Bike honnêtement c'est
un petit bled 200 habitants alors le
tournoi extraordinaire c'est Wimbledon
et tout ça
encore Laurent mais j'ai l'impression
que tu fais la double faute dès le début
de stream sur le mauvais temps je tape
sur le mauvais temps nos amis Nordistes
n'en voudront pas donc il pleut c'est un
petit crachin il fait du truc quand tu
perds ta partie il fait nuit à 16h avec
un disait enfin tu vois c'est vraiment
c'est ambiance et il mange à 19h si tu
veux si tu veux aller si tu veux
chercher un resto à 21h pour faire un
resto bah une heure normal quoi 20h30
21h c'est c'est mort c'est foutu donc
j'ai l'impression que tu es en train
d'écrire notre belle Bretagne sans sans
la mer quoi donc
il fait beau en Bretagne à ce qu'il
paraît maintenant ah bah c'est ça c'est
incroyable c'est le nouvel eldorado ah
ouais je t'avais un petit peu prévenu tu
avais l'info avant tout le monde Laurent
mais bon voilà après après vous en
faites ce que vous voulez mais c'est
vrai que d'ailleurs il y a il y a
maintenant des des migrations vraiment
vers vers notre belle région et du coup
je vous invite à regarder forcément au
moins pour des vacances au moins pour
des vacances on va on va regarder cette
partie entre guillemets cette offre et
on va donner chacun d'entre nous c'est
quoi tu as un tour à préférer toi Kevin
moi je crois que c'est une bonne réponse
quelque chose de Robin des Bois là le
temps après fait le championnat de
France moi j'aime bien parce qu'on
découvre à chaque fois des endroits un
petit peu différents et très sympa tu
vois là Albi cette année c'était
vraiment sympa tu vois il y a eu à jeun
euh il y a eu Chartres
pour le touriste c'est peut-être pas le
la cathédrale est magnifique mais c'est
peut-être pas le meilleur et là il y a
l'Alpe du S cette année moi j'ai hyper
atteint oui l'Alpe d'Huez c'est hyper
bien le problème tu le connais c'est que
pour ma part bah je le joue plus le
choix de France je fais ma colo et du
coup
alors j'aime bien ce que je fais mais je
profite pas du tout quel que soit la
région tu sais que dans ces cas-là
franchement on compte pas nos heures et
on est en mode colo donc du coup
j'aurais bien aimé profiter comme toi de
l'Alpe d'Huez parce que honnêtement j'y
suis allé en avril dernier en vague au
ski et j'avais trouvé ça topissime
topissime d'accord ouais tu vois Nîmes
moi j'ai découvert à chaque fois des
nouvelles villes et c'est vrai que c'est
c'est sympa mais sinon globalement c'est
avec l'Espagne quand même l'Espagne est
sympa les tournois à l'étranger Sitges
j'avais trouvé très sympa
tournoi
dans ce huis clos tu vois dans ce dans
ce centre c'est ça aussi le meilleur
échec quoi le côté fête ouais
donc voilà
je vous conseille franchement en fait je
sais pas je vous conseille si jamais
allez mais c'est un truc j'ai vu la télé
quoi tu vois les étapes où ils montent
du vélo ensemble bien sûr non mais le
vélo c'est c'est la vie un tour de
France avec une polémique en ce moment
niveau vélo godu qui aurait qui aurait
comment dirais-je insulter un de ses
camarades sur son discord d'ailleurs
l'orange c'est pour ça que je te dis ça
sur son discord il a insulté un de ses
camarades et c'est monté très très haut
voilà il a il a été obligé de faire des
excuses publiques pour son sprinter de
son équipe et ça c'était quand même
important de le faire remarquer voilà tu
vois comme quoi discord peut attirer des
ennuis puisque godu le numéro 1 de
l'équipe groupe afdj fait du stream
voilà comme ça vous savez tout pour ceux
qui aiment le vélo et toi l'orange je
sais que ça t'intéresse tout ça voilà ça
me passionne
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe dans ce
garmida m'a accepté et oui on va on va
montrer à tout le monde
la ligne la ligne la plus méchante
tout de suite et on va récupérer ce pion
en C4 donc toujours très dangereux le
vrai challenge pour les Noirs exactement
on a le droit à une variante marginale
un petit peu avec ce fou BK
vous prend ces quatre cavaliers C6 bon
c'est la c'est la classique et après il
y a différentes lignes mon petit rock et
on peut voir fou aussi c'est là il y a
vraiment un carrefour de variante avec
fou prendre B5 avaler B2 bon il y a tout
ça qui est possible mais c'est quand
même assez donc faut B5 c'est assez
annulé il faut prendre ici c'est petit
avantage blanc et qui a validé 2 est
beaucoup moins joué fubécache je connais
beaucoup moins Laurent est-ce que toi
est-ce que spécialiste non pas
spécialiste mais j'ai déjà regardé ça je
suis spécialiste de rien moi tu sais moi
j'ai l'impression que ouais mais bon
Laurent il connaît quand même très bien
certaines choses comme E40 spécialiste
bah quand on bosse avec ma news
forcément on en a un petit peu son pied
peut-être il nous dit pas tout Laurent
il a commencé par nous dire
je vais tout vous dire mais en fait il
reste un peu sur la réserve chauffez-le
un peu dans le chat et va tout vous dire
après ouais alors des deux fous des deux
jouets c'est le coup principal je pense
que c'est trois aussi
un coup réserve mais fou des deux ok
logique le guéri de toute façon lui fait
confiance il faut les quatre échecs il
connaît mais alors on voit le temps des
deux joueurs ouais de cette offre qui a
encore venu bien préparé donc vas-y
peut-être logique il prend dame prend
tout ça c'est vraiment archiologique
cavalier prend bon on a l'impression que
les blancs vont récupérer ces cartes
sans trop de problèmes et avoir un petit
avantage de développement donc un relief
6 cavalier C3
d'un 7 pressing sur le Pione 4 OK et la
grande
hyper intéressant je sais pas j'ai pas
la règle pour cette position j'ai sa
première fois que je la vois ou alors je
m'en souviens pas mais très très
intéressant pour noter que cette offre a
quand même pris pour ce tournoi mais
sans compatriotes mais comme secondant
mais aussi un second ordre classement
mondial
Roustam Kassim Janov qui a une grosse
grosse expérience
ancien secondant de Vichy à Nantes
ancien secondaire de Fabiano caroana le
vraiment
champion du monde
en 2004 à Tripoli mais surtout très très
respecté dans le dans le milieu entre
guillemets pour ses connaissances
théoriques et on voit quand même on voit
la patte de Cassim Abdou satorov qui est
beaucoup mieux préparé que que
d'habitude on voit le résultat immédiat
et c'est très important dans ces
temps-là c'est très dur Laurent ici de
d'évaluer cette situation de rock
opposée il y a eu d'ailleurs petit rock
directement et là on a des rock opposés
qui sont pas si standards très
bordéliques avec ce pion C4 qui est en
prise on doit mettre en place des
schémas de course à l'attaque et je sais
pas quand je vois cette position a
priori je me dis que les Noirs vont
peut-être attaquer plus facilement en
s'appuyant sur les sur les cavaliers
alors c'est peut-être pas faire ça tout
de suite mais globalement on a
l'impression que les les noirs sont pas
si malheureux des congrès très concret
du radiaire parce que là tu vois les
coups là ils jouent F3 pour protéger son
pion le 4 c'est archiologique c'est 5
comme tu l'as dit tu as tout à fait
raison qui a essayé il y a quand même
des problèmes si j'arrive à faire
cavalier
il faut penser 4 dames des six un truc
comme ça
tu es caramel comme on dit dans le dans
le jargon donc faut quand même faire
quelque chose de ce que tu as dit il
faut faire quelque chose de très concret
soit essayer de garder le pion C4 et au
moins on souffre on donne des cases mais
on a un pion en plus donc faut aussi ici
me vient
soit un développement rapide par kss-6
vous pensez qu'à aller au 5 mais il faut
faire quelque chose de dynamique avec
les Noirs à mon avis quelque chose de
une action rapide pour peindre
tranquille il y aura il y aura du dames
du cahier des cinq il faut qu'on
s'écartes du Fou des 5 on arrivera pas à
attaquer facilement assis par exemple
vous pensez 4
B5 et 5 voilà ça c'est chiant
il y a pas l'attaque qui se développe
non donc voilà il faut faire à mon avis
les deux enfin en tout cas j'envoie deux
des coups candidats c'est soit faut
aussi ce qui protège le pion soit qui
est ici qui sont des coups de
développement aussi on a rien on a rien
de sortie quand même avec les Noirs donc
faut quand même bien sûr organiser bien
sûr que je sais pas au feeling moi le
premier coup je regarderai ici c'est fou
aussi mais bon parce que j'aime bien
prendre des pions et pas les rendre
c'est mon côté
j'aime bien le prendre et si je peux ne
pas le rendre ben j'essaie de le faire
je sais pas ce que tu as été comme ça
TOI tu es généreux toi toi
j'ai fort apprécié je trouve que le chat
n'a pas beaucoup réagi à ton expression
tes caramel ça m'a beaucoup plu et je
trouvais que c'était finalement assez
pleure locale pour moi ça me parle en
Bretagne on peut dire ça des caramels on
peut dire ça et je m'adapte tu sais que
j'ai
toutes les expressions bretonnes ce
matin sur sur mon ordi expression
bretonne et ça m'est venu donc elle
était caramel qui est venu donc je le
suis tu as préparé quelques petites
punchline voilà exactement
ah voilà c'est un truc de province sur
les caramels oui oui tout à fait on peut
dire chocolat aussi le grand rock vous
voyez dans le chat dès qu'on vous chope
un petit peu sur les expressions vous
êtes pas mal vous êtes pas mal
continue
tu es invité tu choisis tu choisis
on va on va regarder c'est la bande de
bof de la tâche je la connais c'est
devant un double de la tarrache ça va
faire nul les deux ça a commencé par une
anglaise
on est retombé dans ce genre de schéma
avec un pion isolé potentiel qui arrive
on met notre fond en fiancé
à
avant
7 ici c'est la grande ligne de la
terrasse que je jouais ce que je veux
Gary kasparoff à l'époque dans ces
jeunes années et Daniel duboff le
l'original je peux vu qu'il a été on a
été collègue dans la team Carlson par
deux matchs il est extrêmement
qui a des idées nouvelles à peu près
tout des 30 secondes et donc il a
inventé un système globalement et puis
on prend des cartes qui prend des quatre
sous et 5 qui tient toujours très bien
d'ailleurs voilà et on voit il y a plein
de parties au top niveau et c'est un
système comme un autre franchement il y
a pas de problème particulier pour les
Noirs extraordinaire d'ailleurs dans ces
parties dans la base on se régale avec
quelques petites idées bien senti quand
vous sortez une idée de double on a
encore récemment vu même au championnat
de
il a sorti des idées assez incroyables
il est plein de créativité c'est génial
mais il a sorti une belle une très très
belle idée récemment ce qui est dommage
alors c'est ce que je lui ai dit moi je
l'engueule je lui dis écoute il faut
faire mieux en particulier avec un
talent un talent comme ça il a à peine
entre guillemets entre guillemets il a
2700 2 3 je sais pas Facebook autour de
2710 de 1720 mais tu vois c'est
quelqu'un avec le talent qu'il a moi je
verrai pas loin de 2008 tu vois ok mais
c'est quoi le conseil c'est quoi le son
problème toi Laurent qui est qui est
plus éclairé que nous
[Musique]
je pense pas parfaite parce que ça
n'existe pas perfection c'est quand même
très très haut de gamme mais il y a un
moment où il s'enflamme un peu trop il
veut faire tu vois il veut jouer le tu
vois c'est quand tu fais je sais pas un
joueur de foot qui va t'enchaîner un
Neymar qui attendra dribbles et qui va
faire celui trop le faire la passe tu
vois c'est un compliment
il joue le un peu trop les échecs
champagne
toi qui aime bien le tennis peut-être un
petit peu voilà
l'enflammable à la carglios mais il
commence à devenir dangereux alors
attention à duboff peut-être et
attention ouais mais attention 96 c'est
la génération Richard import donc 96 ça
fait 27 ans quand à 27 ans aujourd'hui
aux échecs
tu étais plus tu es plus un jeune
premier
il y en a qui sont encore plus âgées du
coup
voilà bon ça a continué c'est tout à
fait théorique pour l'instant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et du mal de notre chat s'il te plaît
c'est pas c'est pas du tout mon style
Laurent qui me disait que je fasse plus
d'échecs il est un peu stressé
aujourd'hui pour pour sa première
surchais comme il a envie de très très
bien faire vous voyez que vous allez
bien en plus
si tu regardais des manchots
tu verrais que je mets souvent sur le
costume et c'est pas mon vrai je vais te
corriger encore une fois c'est pas mon
premier show j'avais fait des choix à
l'époque c'était il y a 4-5 ans j'avais
commandé des speechs ok d'accord
c'est un truc que j'ai continué à
commenter sur chaise 24 même si c'était
un événement de nos frères de
chaises.com voilà on était quand même le
speechess et un format qui me plaît
beaucoup de Bleach je sais pas ce que tu
en penses j'aime bien mais il y a une
chambre
c'est-à-dire que des fois les matchs
n'ont plus d'intérêt quand il y a une
grosse raclée donc on pourrait couper
c'est 1h30 une heure et 30 minutes au
cas danse 5 + 1 3 + 1 1 + 1 et du coup
on pourrait faire quelque chose comme
une heure 45 minutes et qu'un une heure
ouais voilà une heure trente minutes et
15 minutes peut-être ça serait ça serait
un format encore plus speed ça serait le
very speech voilà Laurent et je pense
que ce serait plus adapté parce que des
fois il y a des grosses raclées ouais
mais il y a quand même beaucoup de
matchs tendus plus en avance plus étendu
c'est vrai bah le nacre c'était pas mal
quand même pour certains parce que j'ai
commandé j'ai commenté la Carlson en
anglais évidemment j'avais vibré devant
François Argentine quelques heures plus
tôt dis non c'est la journée
quand même parce que là ça faisait ça
faisait 7 heures de déception bon ça
c'est super beaucoup c'est sûr c'est sûr
donc ça cette position j'ai déjà vu
notamment dans une partie du bœuf Carson
double Carson avec les Blancs c'était
dans un championnat du monde de Blitz ou
de Blitz ouais ou Magnus l'emporter au
final mais ça va rien avoir avec le
début tour des 8 ok donc c'est rigolo
parce que maintenant c'est cette
tendance d'avoir ce type de structure
l'idée Laurent c'est de contrôler
simplement les quatre pions là
on n'a pas de problème quoi exactement
Kevin et il faut noter que ce qui est
amusant c'est que la finale de tour
admettons on échange tout s'échange à
l'eldame si on a si on se retrouve avec
tour 4 pions contre tour 3 pions sur ml
en fait avec les pions doublés c'est
très très facile à défendre il y a
besoin de rien faire ce qu'on peut
jamais se créer un pion passé donc on
contrôle très bien les quatre pions
donc c'est exactement ça et les les
pions sont pas sont pas vraiment faibles
et on a le tandem [ __ ] pour pour
compenser à zeldame pour travailler à la
dame et salut Robinson et salut à JBM
FFE je pense que tu le connais
bon donc ton rêve c'est un jouet par
les von Aronian logique qui attaque le
pion faut aussi ce qui défend
indirectement le pion à cause de tout
reprendre ici à la petite tactique vous
prend V3
et fin
et tu sais quoi il aurait pu même faire
ici Faby il aurait pu faire [ __ ] en V3
et tourner deux à mon avis il faut
prendre les trois après en V3 tu
reprends un tour prends un tour des deux
à mon avis
ça c'est nul mais il a voulu il donne
même pas ça en fait il fait tour à 4 et
en gros il dit à
[Musique]
dans le tournoi on a vu il me semble que
ça te RAF si je dis pas de bêtises
défendre le roi 4
exactement
et je l'avais j'avais annoncé dans le
stream anglais je faisais extrêmement
anglais avec Peter's vide là et en fait
j'avais parlé j'avais fait exactement la
même remarque que je refais et ça et 30
coups plus tard ça c'était terminé comme
ça et c'était une partie de carbonade
déjà mais là tu vois je crois qu'il en
veut même pas en fait il fait 3 4
il s'active c'est vrai que ce qui est
connu Laurent c'est que le roi 4 contre
roi 3 avec une tour chacun c'est très
facilement nul quand les pions sont liés
mais là avec cette structure là on
aurait pu penser que les Blancs
pouvaient chercher à gagner alors
chercher à gagner on peut toujours mais
en tout cas ça fait ça fait nul c'est
très difficile voir impossible de passer
sur un jeu normal quoi ouais c'est ça et
c'est même hyper simple à jouer pour les
Noirs c'est ça aussi
tour à 4 et là on peut même faire tour à
8 non
je sais pas où c'est 5 je sais pas
n'importe quel coup à peu près normal
je cherche retour rapide ce que je
voulais blanc puis ce qui est déjà pas
si facile
tu sais à l'aveugle je tiens je pense
que j'arrive à tenir mais c'est pas sûr
c'est pas sûr pour l'instant tu évite
tous les confrontations à l'aveugle je
sais pas si si les gens vont réussir à
suivre je suis un peu inquiet
j'aurais fait des flèches j'aurai fait
des flèches
alors du coup est-ce que tu rêves non
parce qu'il y a une très mauvaise
nouvelle
si je te prends le pionisme vas-y
est une assez mauvaise nouvelle avec ce
du couloir un peu bizarre en fait c'est
pas mal mais en tout cas on est obligé
de donner une pièce donc non
je sais pas ce que c'est l'idée
peut-être pas bouger les pièces
maintenant pour Laurent
on voulait vous faire progresser à la
vogue mais Laurent a besoin de bouger
les pièces aujourd'hui voilà non mais je
sais même pas comment on garde le pion
là
tu me disais de bouger les pièces
attention ne pas bouger vos pièces trop
vite voilà mais c'est pas si facilement
bah d'ailleurs c'est pour c'est un
métier facilement
t'inquiète pas allez on met le frein à
main avec l'idée cavaliers
qui est un peu la même idée c'est
surtout prends à deux tours prend à deux
et cavaliers
et une belle signature il se connaissent
bien les deux joueurs
quand même bien sûr d'être un peu
fatigué bon il y aura nul dans celle-là
c'est à peu près garanti
ensuite on va avoir une autre partie
alors qui c'est que tu as envie d'aller
voir gamer il doit émerger
tu vois mal choisi mais tu as joué cette
partie là Laurent d'ailleurs contre
Sébastien Mazet on était un fan
[Rires]
pardon puis on prend dans ma 54 bien sûr
qui était une prépa qui était pas
destinée pour moi au départ mais bon
ouais
c'est le à l'époque non je pense pas je
pense que c'est je connais c'est quand
même quand tu l'avais joué c'est pour ça
que ça m'avait intéressé je me rappelle
bien sûr oui tu connaissez ah oui la
Crau tu sais que c'est c'est mon plaisir
la colonne donc du coup
je connais bien oui du coup
mais peut-être que c'est une partie
j'avais je sais je sais pas si elle est
dans la base tu vas nous confirmer mais
il me semble effectivement que le rang
n'a rien inventé la là-dessus c'est pas
moi de toute façon j'ai dit que c'était
pas une idée pour moi c'était un truc ce
truc là
attention il y a le cavalier on a obligé
de tout accepter tourner donc on
continue à harceler la dame qui défend
le cavalier et là on a un problème parce
que si on fait d'un Massac ou dame C3 ça
va être tombé 5 dame C3 pour garder le
clouage et là il y a fou B2 qui fait
très très mal et on encaisse la tour et
donc ça va pas pour les noirs on peut
pas faire quel est le 4G j'avais gagné
au final contre contre maso une partie
qui aurait pu être importante mais
malheureusement j'ai perdu ma je vais
partager c'est sympa de me rappeler des
mauvais souvenirs on a pas fait exprès
tu as quand même gagné la partie au
début on se rappelle de la partie et toi
tu fais un certain mal gamme c'était la
même journée les malgés
je dis un coucou amical à nos amis qui
sont sur le chat de chaise 24 évidemment
les parties sont retransmises sur chaise
24 je me fais chambrer par Wims mais ça
c'est normal voilà voir take fresque
commentaire
voilà on a réussi j'ai réussi mon
objectif de vie je te remercie mon cher
Winx et n'hésitez pas à venir sur la
chaîne twitch de euh
voilà n'hésitez pas à venir emmener un
petit un petit pouce en s'abonne où on
vient sur la chaîne Youtube aussi de
chaise comme fr n'hésitez pas même si
c'est pas d'actualité j'en ai discuté
avec les
[Musique]
responsables de chez som de fermer quoi
que ce soit sur chaise 24 et
éventuellement tu vois aujourd'hui si tu
avais été un peu meilleur niveau
informatique on aurait pu diffuser ça
sur chaise comme FR et chaise 24 fr en
même temps sur Youtube et twitch mais
comme tu avais pas la clé du restreint
je t'ai pas du tout responsable c'est un
dire de que vous pouvez taper sur
robinsight par contre à la limite lui je
les prendra large pour moi robinside il
sera d'accord il sera d'accord
maintenant je suis pas responsable
Laurent du tout la spectacle
donc ça sera le projet quand on aura
quand on aura voilà de faire ça surtout
des chaînes vu que c'est un et c'est un
seul groupe donc ça a tous son sens en
fait de diffuser un peu partout et de de
pas perdre des gens en route bien sûr
donc du coup on continue l'autre façon
classique de jouer alors il y a une
partie dans la base d'Adrien de Mute qui
joue un joueur 2300 sur ce truc là avec
B4 C4 E3 et on peut jouer j'ai trois je
crois aussi des fois ça joue aussi soit
avec E3 soit avec G3 et on met le four
en B2 par contre Laurent je sais pas du
tout on peut faire ces quatre j'imagine
suivi de b403 il avait B4 et là c'est
rigolo dame C3
après pourquoi
je vois pas de toute façon on va on va
donner le tempo de non mais disons on va
voir ce qu'il a fait dans la partie dame
C7 au lieu d'un C3 d'AMS c'est ça qui te
perturbe c'est qu'il est provoqué la
tour en beurre moi je trouve
et peut-être un peu moins bien placé en
B1 quand A1 tu perds pas de temps
pourquoi elle est très bon bien placé en
verre on sait jamais un petit fou F5 qui
pour arriver plus tard ok d'accord on
peut imaginer on peut imaginer un petit
A5 et et apprend B4 et c'est moi qui ai
la colonne ba bon moi je me disais
naïvement si tu veux que le fou qui
arrive en GSA de fou B2 est pas protégé
etc bon bon ok c'est pas qu'on a la même
position et là ouais là bah dans le chat
vous nous dit rien si vous voyez des
c'est pour ou contre
ok bon c'est assez normal ce qui se
passe
ouais honnêtement les deux joueurs
sortent leurs pièces là on va voir ils
se développent normalement donc là on
voit ces quatre B6 ok j'ai déjà vu
quasiment cette position soit avec j'ai
trois fougères soit le fond en deux soit
le fond des trois mètres se font un peu
partout mais on fait toujours ça très
facile un centre Tour Eiffel 8 bon faut
m'expliquer l'idée
Kevin au hasard moi je sais pas là moi
je préfère jouer avec les Blancs cette
position
à titre perso les positions stylées riz
sont hippopotame là sur trois rangées
mais tu sais quoi je crois que tout revu
c'est pas un coup utile mais le problème
c'est que les Noirs ont déjà quand on
regarde le setup des noix on se dit
qu'on est quasiment au max tu vois et
donc en fait on va attendre on va
attendre que les que les que les Blancs
fassent quelque chose alors je sais pas
quelle va être le plan mais peut-être
tranquillement jouer à un moment au 4
alors je vais pas tout de suite mais
pour avoir
regardé avec l'ordi ce type de position
c'est quand même dur de passer avec les
Blancs
[Musique]
si la tour était en 1 d'ailleurs on
aurait peut-être un 4 à 5 comme comme
plan qui était Matic plutôt dans les
maroilles
et si l'adversaire nous balance à un 5
on peut peut-être gagner cette case là
après il faut que tu as de l'anticiper
en mettant le terrain on a en gagné on
en Ampère on perd ses 5 aussi dans ce
que tu as dit ça c'est toujours c'est
ces structures de Hérisson ou dès qu'on
commence à pousser comme tu l'as dit
c'est pas facile avec les Blancs si on
commence à pousser alors on va gagner
des cases on va perdre d'autres donc
faut voir mais gamer il a l'habitude
quand même tu l'as dit tout à l'heure il
a raté beaucoup de parties mais quand
même le gros point positif pour gamer
c'est qu'il arrive à dominer
régulièrement il prend du monde bien sûr
que non mais il est dominent quoi il
vaut mieux que pendant 30-35 coups donc
après il rate des trucs oui au chat
devant des combien j'aurais fait dans
ces finales de Tours moi j'ai le
problème c'est que franchement après 6
heures de jeu
honnêtement je fais plus un point je
veux dire non mais c'est dur quoi c'est
très dur c'est très dur c'est cadence ça
dure une éternité ça dure trois semaines
se tournoi 6 heures de jeu on peut pas
lui en vouloir c'est c'est particulier
Vikings c'est ce qui fait le charme
aussi mais c'est ça fait aussi sa
difficulté on peut pas blâmer gamer
c'est pas facile c'est final le tour
qu'il a eu quand même oui d'autant plus
qu'il l'a pas si mal joué mais il a fait
une grosse bourde en un coup ce roi le
synchrophe
oui il faut passer le roi d'abord mais
c'est vrai que ça final la plus récente
forest où il pouvait gagner ouais mais
c'était ouais je trouve non c'est en
fait maintenant on a les ordis donc à
chaque fois on refuse que de etc mais
objectivement comme il est resté
longtemps avec l'avantage on a
l'impression que c'était très facile à
faire un coup à côté BIM nul donc non ça
ça peut être ça peut être vraiment dur
tu es très dur la finale de tour donc on
va pas lui entre autre chose
lui
particulièrement je pense et du coup ça
peut être parfait non plus quoi c'est
trop dur donc qui joue sur C8 Richie
Boys et il va y avoir du mb8
et ouais il a pas peur et tout va tout
va à peu près bien pour les noirs sans
être
pas très très rigolo
est-ce qu'on continue notre tour un
petit tour on me demande si j'ai
connu madame Chaudet oui j'ai connu la
même chose il a connu beaucoup de choses
on va pas dire son âge dans le stream ça
ne se fait pas mais j'ai connu j'ai vu
jouer j'ai joué contre Kaisa à l'époque
où il y avait madame chaude qui est
occupait
son échiquier donc j'ai connu j'ai vu
jouer madame Chaudet on va regarder
allez
voir
je me suis dit que tu voulais aller voir
les joueurs indiens avec iriga izi oula
oui d'accord alors on va les regarder
comment comment s'est passé donc c'est
une
avec une variante cavalière H4 dans
cette dans cette config et ce qui est
intéressant j'ai regardé ça récemment et
ce qui est intéressant c'est que le coût
principal ici c'était de jouer fujiste
tout le temps les gens jouaient 100 % du
temps fou les 6 et maintenant la grande
mode c'est de jouer fou et 4 dans ce
qu'il a joué dans la partie pour
provoquer pas trop je pense que c'est ça
qui est qui doit être pénible cavalier
prend un cas les deux sont bons quand il
prend 4 c'est très bon siècle B400
on peut pas le prendre en tout cas et on
joue F3 et après il faut G6 on a
exactement la même position mais les
Blancs ont poussé F3 ce qui est
affaiblissant pour la structure on le
comprend parce qu'il peut y avoir ces
cinq les cases noires sont un peu plus
faibles mais ça aide aussi à pousser
trois ou quatre donc c'est à double
tranchant mais apparemment la la
disons le verdict en ce moment en tout
cas après c'est des modes c'est toujours
pareil le verdict en ce moment c'est
qu'il faut provoquer F3 parce que c'est
affaiblissant pour les blancs voilà les
les joueurs noirs du côté noir préfèrent
quasiment exclusivement
provoquer F3 ok c'est intéressant de
toute façon Laurent comment tu fais pour
pour savoir tu regardes simplement les
parties à plus de 2007 comment tu tiens
toi qui prépare enfin qui seconde Magnus
Carson comment ça se passe vraiment tu
fais confiance au parti de plus de 2016
ou c'est quoi la limite un petit peu ou
alors
2007 après il y a les parties par
correspondance qui sont quand même une
grosse source d'info aussi bien sûr mais
voilà mais après les modes ouais les
modes top niveau c'est c'est vraiment
washirof chirofijou que ça c'est quand
même un expert de la slave il faut se
fout 4 extra fogestis guérit en a fait
pas mal aussi donc c'est un peu la la
mafia entre guillemets hollandaise voilà
tous les jours hollandais il joue ça
donc ils ont ils ont lancé une mode et
tout le monde copie bien sûr voilà ça
fait longtemps que j'ai pas vu une
partie un joueur très fort à plus de 26
50 disons avec
ok donc on continue
donc au bout d'un moment on va jouer sur
casse blanche on vraisemblablement et on
joue de la dame V3 déjà pour mettre une
bonne pression et là c'est étonnant le
coup qui va jouer ici on donne parce
qu'ici sur MP3 on joue quasi
automatiquement soit d'ams7 soit dame B6
plutôt peut-être dans ce genre de
situation
dame c'est 7 d'ailleurs parce que ça
contre-attaque un petit peu H2 ensuite
avec les noix on pourra faire
éventuellement un coup de cavalier 17 B6
pour forcer une décision des blancs
et ensuite je vais jouer B6 et si tu
prends des 5 je suis content parce que
je reprends du Pione ou du pion C j'ai
peut-être une case C4 et là il fait un
coup ah bah je suis concret du coup il
joue puis on prend C4 ce qui est très
étonnant parce que l'idée l'idée ici
c'est vraiment d'activer
le fou F1 pour les blancs et donc là on
a l'impression que Jordan il rentre dans
le jeu adverse quoi ouais donc le
problème de fou français il a pas fait
faut penser 4 parce que surtout quand
c'est que je suppose que l'idée c'est B5
et fou qu'elle est fou tu veux ou deux
et je voulais 3 parce qu'il y aurait
cavaliers c'est 5 ouais certainement que
c'est 5 x 2 et déjà je vais faire à 6
c'est 5 rapidement et normalement ça va
ce genre de position on a le temps de
pour le faire je crois mais pas
complètement clair d'ailleurs parce que
si j'ai pas A4 il y aura B4 et C5
quelque chose comme ça
respire pas ok bon on imagine mais en
tout cas c'est vrai que c'est étonnant
en plus le pire dans cette décision là
en fait il devait connaître quand même
parce qu'il laisse à la fois faut
prendre ces quatre qui est quand même
pas limpide même s'il y a B5 on le
comprend Laurent avec ce que tu as dit
mais il y a quand même dame tromper ça
qui a été joué dans la partie c'est ça
ouvrir vraiment les cases blanches il y
a toujours sous conséquate de
possibilités il a pas peur ils fonce
dans les complications c'est ce qui
caractérise il essaie vraiment de jouer
la ligne correcte même si il fait face à
une prépa il a pas peur et sur ces cinq
bon ok il faut prendre sa carte qui est
déjà un coup qu'on peut regarder mais il
y a cavalier B5 qui est encore plus
concret pour aller chercher la casse C7
et la mort du roi noir quoi exactement
et là tour B8 c'est sans doute une
préparation noire ce qu'on joue avec le
roi en E7 on va jusqu'au bout avec les
avec les Blancs
et là on s'est engagé il faut pas perdre
le cavalier c'est ça en route quoi c'est
ça
on protège on contrôle la case à 8 avec
le cavaliers donc tout va bien
et vite tu as vu comment il a pas peur
dingue c'est quand même incroyable
on se rappelle de sa partie contre
caroanna au candidats 2020 exact où il
rentre dans une énorme prépa et gagne
quand même il trouve tous les coups ils
gagnent c'est un semi bluff de la part
de de Fabiano Carola mais comme souvent
d'ailleurs là je suis pas sûr qu'il
yorden il soit soit complètement
convaincu tu vois de la
par la position noire mais tu te dis
s'il y a 5 ou 6 coups très dur à trouver
pour les gens mais pourquoi pas en fait
en pratique c'est pas mal c'est un bon
essai c'était sûr de surprendre et
d'ailleurs c'est parti pour la
complications à partir on voit on a les
couleurs on aille sans module comme un
comme à chaque fois mais en tout cas on
a les couleurs et apparemment dépenser 5
vous l'avez vu à la jauge de toute façon
c'était pas le mieux tourbé 7 alors le
quel était le mieux d'ailleurs enfin le
mieux
il a passé un quart d'heure il a pas
trouvé et tu dis Laurent on joue quoi
elle rentre elle est là pour ça hein tu
es là pour ça c'est là pour nous
éclairer je peux dire qu'avec souvent on
trouve des très jolies coups bon des
fois des moins beaucoup
non mais là tu es marrant là j'en sais
rien moi c'est hyper hyper concrète
cette position je sais pas regarder
je peux pas leur dire on fait un petit
effort on fait un petit effort non on
peut regarder on sait on sait en plus
j'ai peur mais c'est dur de trouver un
coup bah oui tu as le père de ce
cavalier
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que tu nous as trouvé
des comptes chauffe un peu Laurent tu
vois tu sors de ta zone de confort et
incroyable c'est hyper intéressant on va
voir je vais jouer dans ma 5 rue bien la
jauge
voilà tu as vu et voilà
c'était peut-être pas le coup
je suis pas sûr ah non non je pense que
c'était ça regarde toute façon
je mets la variante donc là on vous dit
et Damas 5 meilleur coup vous voyez je
t'en prie merci
Laurent tu manques de confiance en toi
fais-toi confiance
Laurent je te remercie c'est vrai en
plus demain 5 bah ouais tu gardes le
Caval mais qu'est-ce que je fais j'avais
pensé
pour rien en fait
c'est pareil quand même oui mais par
rapport comme c'est on savait que
c'était pas le bon coup du coup
franchement c'était une question cadeau
à laquelle Laurent a fait une attention
ton ordi là il est profondeur 20 alors
très bien chaise.com nos frères mais
c'est quand même pas faut se méfier
Jordan quand il analyse c'est plus haut
bien sûr bien sûr c'est pour ça qu'on
fait très attention quand on met la
jauge Laurent tu fais bien de le dire
mais en fait la jauge des fois c'est
pour ça qu'elle a baissé un petit peu un
moment quand tu as proposé d'un Massac
mais elle a une fiabilité relative bon
là on voit que c'était quand même sans
doute le meilleur coup d'un Massac
pourquoi il n'a pas joué bah il y a des
complications derrière Laurent commencer
à regarder trop promet d'eux il y avait
beaucoup de coups il y a essayé de
prendre des cartes donc il a préféré
calmer les choses il a eu peur de se
prendre des 4 sans doute d'ailleurs les
choses tu parles il perd une pièce quand
même oui mais il j'ai prévu un petit C6
qui marche qu'à moitié je
suppose du coup
pas en 8 pourquoi Laurent parce que
pas sûr mais c'est même pas sûr roi 8
vas-y échec ah non il y a puis on prend
je voulais faire mais à 8 on peut pas
m'invite
peut-être
et attention
il y a B2 aussi en l'air
ok mais j'ai le foot 15 blanche
je voulais gloutonner ces quatre est-ce
que j'ai le droit pour essayer de te
mettre fou B5 parce que j'ai le casque
blanche
c'était chaleur
pour tout le monde quoi
je voulais faire [ __ ]
ça marche pas
4 comme ça je te crée un je te faisais
peur mais il y a [ __ ] en B4 dame prend
C4 et Damas 8
je n'avais pas regardé quand tu l'as dit
j'ai regardé j'avais pas regardé ok faut
prendre des cartes étaient dans les
réseaux de maths donc en fait
ça va pas vous voyez un
donc
le deuxième coup évidemment sur ces 6
c'est roi D8 qui donne pas qui donne pas
le cavalier sur échec
qu'est-ce qu'il a prévu sur roi D8
pour clouer la dame et comme ça
c'est magnifique ça doit être ça
pour Laurent tu me fais que proposer de
la Massac mais tu as raison
c'est magnifique ça magnifique bravo
belle fourchette
un clouage qui maintient la fourchette
mignon je vois je vois trois cerises qui
posent une question sur mon compte chez
sebul nos frères du Play Magnus group
donc cheese.com en fait toute la famille
chez sébble à un moment coach estable il
devait sortir à Noël à Noël dernier mais
j'ai retard donc on sait pas trop et
c'est sûr c'est un lifetime répertoire
sur la
Sicilienne je suis à
part on prend tous les coups et
franchement je me suis vu un peu trop
ambitieux là parce que c'est quand même
c'est énormément de boulot je m'étais
pas rendu compte et
je galère je suis en retard grave
[Musique]
je t'ai senti confiant un moment alors
ouais je fais confiance au début mais là
je galère non je suis très très loin
d'avoir fini je sais pas comment ça va
sortir si ça sort avant le prochain Noël
ça sera déjà pas mal tu as envie de
faire quelque chose tracé à la règle
j'imagine et du coup voilà tu te donnes
du mal et du coup c'est c'est aussi
normal les ouvertures c'est chronophages
vous le savez et on peut dire que
les sujets traités par chasse aveugle
sont en général très qualitatifs c'est
gros gros niveau
ce qui est un peu étonnant d'ailleurs ça
manque de choses un peu plus tout public
mais
en tout cas moi mais c'est vrai que la
cible tu le dis tu as raison et ça a
peut-être changé d'ailleurs avec le
l'arrivée de chaise.com évidemment qui
touchait plus tu vois ces joueurs un
petit peu plus débutants tout simplement
et donc c'est vrai que ça
s'adresse plutôt à des joueurs de club
et des joueurs de club motivés qui ont
tendance à quand même à acheter beaucoup
de cours voilà
je comprends Laurent mais par exemple la
cible de ton de ton pack là sur la
science-ficov c'est quel est le et
l'autre départ
je prends tous les coups de A à Z ah
d'accord ok ok donc c'est E4 c'est 5 et
maintenant on voit tout donc là j'ai
fait d'accord ok le premier chapitre est
fini donc il y a 3 B3 B4 ah oui d'accord
F4 G3 cavalier F3
cavalier 3
damage 5 et analysé tous ces quatre et
analysés
le travail de fourmis
travail de fourmis
donc voilà donc je reviens la position
donc on voit Jordan en pleine réflexion
et puis minutes tu le dis moi je rêve
d'un livre qui m'explique comment
utiliser le chaise base
c'est très simple tu as l'aide de chaise
basse déjà qui peut t'aider il y a des
tutos aussi sur Youtube qui doivent
exister voilà donc tu as quand même
moyen de faire certaines choses voilà
alors bon là c'est la pagaille ça va
être passionnante à suivre cette partie
est-ce qu'on peut pas finirait pas notre
tour des stats pour aller revoir après
peut-être Magnus et les deux parties
donc
début de tournois très très difficile et
ensuite ici et c'est quand même bien
remis avec deux victoires tarif a
toujours toujours à 0 victoire je crois
et 3 défaites mais bon
consécutives en plus on met deux
partenaires de club puisque Google
rejoint Mulhouse maintenant pour le
prochain Top 16 donc c'est tout de la
team là avec qu'on a dans notre équipe
de Mulhouse
vous avez pas les voix si vous les voyez
cette année ça peut-être mais pas
beaucoup plus
en profiter exactement
donc là on est dans quelque chose que tu
connais très très bien parce que c'est
une position que tu as déjà joué Laurent
avec
au début d'ailleurs je me rappelle
d'ailleurs d'une partie que tu as fait
contre un joueur anglais donc c'était
gawan Jones voilà sur ça
et du coup ce qui était assez rigolo
c'est une ligne enfin qui peut être vu
comme une ligne de nulle
Laurent ici
très très joué et c'est toi qui était
arrivé avec une petite idée Laurent non
dans la fin
tu nous rappelles c'était dame trois le
dame 4
beaucoup de joueurs font nuls aussi de
manière un petit peu classique c'est une
huile de Grand Maître on va dire dans
cette position et
d'avoir plus d'une dizaine de parties
dans la base simplement avec les Noirs
jamais fait ça avec les Blancs
et donc il y a un joueur qui est arrivé
avec une petite idée contre toi donc
Gaën Joss et il a joué damot 3 dame 3 et
3 j'ai joué fois 6 il a joué qui C3
il faut faire un petit peu gaffe parce
que mine de rien alors que ça semblait
être le choix de la nulle pour les
blancs avec une sorte d'essuie-glace là
et on faisait nul cette position pose
encore quelques petits soucis pratiques
au noir et il faut être précis pour pour
obtenir la nul donc je crois que j'ai
joué ouais pardon excuse-moi c'était pas
c'était pas passionnant j'ai dû jouer
aux 7 ici qui est pas peut-être pas le
plus précis je crois qu'il faut jouer à
6 euh
justement voilà on avait joué cette
position MC6 cahier des 4 et il avait
isolé le pion mais tu avais pris de la
dame pour avoir la finale et faire nul
exactement
ça se tient confortablement quand même
ok donc là cavalier prend des 4 il y a
normalement
donc il y a la vente qu'on a vu avec des
5 peut prendre des 6 et là voilà c'est
ça alors ça
ça c'est surprenant
dangereux parce que quand même il y a la
paire de fou et un pion central pour les
Noirs donc tu as quand même l'impression
ici qu'avec les blancs tu vois tu as
même pas les pièces sorties tu as pas
besoin d'avantage tu peux même te
retrouver moins bien potentiellement tu
as l'impression qu'il faut faire quelque
chose de d'assez rapide tu vois de créer
des menaces et là il le fait pas du tout
donc c'est parce que
normalement donc un 4 est assez
intéressant mais on la joue beaucoup
moins à cause de cavaliers des quatre il
y a aussi le coût qu'est-ce qu'on peut
jouer
la ligne avec D6 c'est ici D6 non c'est
peut-être sur un 4 je sais plus
voilà c'est une partie d'ailleurs entre
Quentinois et tigrane-garmian un pot car
menteur au national ou ici il faut jouer
E6 si je dis pas de bêtises Laurent
c'est ça
il y a plusieurs couilles apprendre
médecin aussi qui se jouent je crois
mais aussi c'est le ouais le coup le
plus le plus dangereux et il s'est
complètement trompé Quentin qui avait
joué ça pour faire nul il était pas trop
au courant de D6 et du coup il avait
sombré dès ce moment-là on a donc faut
quand même faire attention il y a des
connaissances à avoir mais bon là les
joueurs d'élite comme le son irrigaziz
et connaissent tout par contre des 5 C3
j'ai jamais vu en fait tu as déjà vu toi
ce coup-là je crois pas non ouais donc
du coup si on voit que c'est quand même
des prépas de de très haut niveau parce
que pour le coup E45 tu restes
spécialiste mondial non Laurent quand
même est-ce que c'est tu trouves ça
impressionnant
impressionnant je sais pas non mais je
peux pas dire ça honnêtement
on voit l'idée de balancer F4 si si on
peut balancer f4f5
bah là on ferait peur mais il y a le
Pione qui est en l'air
donc bah ça paraît bah ça paraît pas bon
après si on a l'impression que les Noirs
effectivement ils ont égalisé puisque
toutes les cases blanches sont ouvertes
en plus
je suis assez d'accord et Laurent
Laurent comment dire alors on demande
tiens du second de plus Magnus c'est
Lucas qui nous demande ça
c'est à dire que depuis que les matchs
se sont arrêtés effectivement il y a
moins d'intensité et là c'est ça dépend
aussi de ces projets en fait voilà c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué c'est pas
complètement finalisé pour ce tournoi
non
voilà clairement mais c'est pas exclu à
l'avenir
donc c'est vrai que normalement je
secondais notamment pour les matchs
champion du monde et ça fait de
nombreuses années maintenant depuis donc
depuis 2013 première champion du monde
et depuis 2015 quasiment à chaque
tournoi de partylon alors évidemment
quand je vous parle par exemple il a
joué Olympiades cet été donc je l'ai pas
aidé je l'ai aidé l'année dernière par
le tournoi du norwei pendant les
quelques rondes de Saint-Louis aussi
j'ai donc voilà donc normalement je
travaillais pendant les tournois de
parties on met effectivement pas pour
celui-là voilà donc ça se on verra je
sais pas aussi ça dépend de lui aussi
s'il veut je pense qu'il veut en fait
continuer à jouer toi de partie longue
ce qui me semblait pas complètement
évident tu vois avec ces tournois
maintenant
alors effectivement maintenant il y en a
moins du coup parce qu'on avait le mail
Twitter champion de chaise tour tu vois
qu'il y avait 10 tournois dans l'année
et chaise.com qui avait énormément de
tournois et c'est vrai que la fusion
fait que finalement ils ont fait un gros
circuit avec 6 tournois c'est vrai qu'on
était un peu
on était un peu en mode overdose de ces
tournois online à 6 tournois dans
l'année c'est bien sûr je comprends je
comprends bien après il voit tout toute
la jeunesse arrivée elle a envie de les
calmer peut-être et de montrer qui est
le patron ça doit lui faire plaisir de
voir aussi du sang frais entre
guillemets
oui
bien sûr je pense qu'il aime tous les
tous les défis et donc de jouer ces
jeunes joueurs il les découvre et je
pense qu'il aime beaucoup et d'ailleurs
je sais pas si tu regardes des petites
vidéos de Tata style mais il analyse
normalement il fait pas ça et il analyse
il analyse avec les jeunes joueurs il a
envie de comprendre comment il joue non
mais c'est je crois pas que ça soit
vraiment pour améliorer ses résultats ou
tu vois une idée derrière la tête tu
vois je vais comprendre comment il joue
comme ça je vais voir la faiblesse et
tout ça c'est juste qu'il est curieux il
aime le jeu il est que de voir leur
style et c'est un super compétiteur et
c'est vrai que ce qui nous a étonné
d'ailleurs avec Stéphane qu'on était aux
commentaires c'est de le voir même quand
il a perdu rester à l'échiquier
presque souriant voilà et
c'est pas c'était pas la il était pas
désinvolte mais il avait envie de jouer
il avait envie d'échanger il était dans
un dans une posture
je sais pas ouais de vraiment se faire
plaisir aux échecs en tout cas donc du
coup je suis pas trop étonné que ce que
tu dis
donc on va regarder
ça clairement il voulait il voulait
prendre en C6 et après je me suis pris
on voit ça dans le Gambier écossais par
exemple vous voyez prise Laurent nous
dit hop créer 6 attaque la dame donc on
a pas le temps de faire du coin
intermédiaire
et là le jeu sur case noir serait
facilité
pour mettre le cavalier en B3 on
travaillera des cases
exactement donc il prend
étonnant je trouve aussi on prend c'est
naturel mais en même temps ton fouet est
vraiment moche dans la reprise avec le
client on pourrait peut-être
5 c'est déjà l'âme des 7 c'est 6 je sais
pas quelque chose j'ai 4 mais il y a
[ __ ] malheureusement c'est toi ça
ouais mais il y a pas il y a pas des
trois sinon j'y allais
c'était intéressant
donc et puis là tu vas voir le temps de
mettre une petite amandes aisselle les
cases blanches sont vraiment
sont vraiment moches donc du coup il y a
eu fou prends des quatre
du coup qu'il laisse ses 5 et l'idée
on doit changer la structure sinon après
faute 3 on va être tout à fait coincé je
vais commencer à ouvrir je vais jouer
des quatre et mes fouilles vont jouer je
vais même mettre commencer à jouer pour
l'avantage complètement ça peut ça peut
se retourner à ce genre de truc hein
donc plus on prend M6 ça devient
tactique
se pose la question aussi GF dans cette
position juste pour contrôler la case E5
roi H8 et après on joue sur la colonne g
bon c'est c'est assez fantasque comme
approche on a peut-être pas besoin de ça
dans cette position c'est très simple je
trouve que c'est intéressant mais bon ça
se regarde mais il a décidé de pas le
faire c'était probablement pas pas
mauvais mais beaucoup plus risqué ok
parce que cette position
c'est quand même hyper chaud mais je ne
peux pas facilement reprendre en décaps
et j'aurais pu essayer de jouer bon
cavalier qu'on devrait fou mais j'ai un
problème
en un coup avec dames 3 et chaque qui va
arriver donc d'un F3 était joué
ok c'est pas
C3 et c'est au noir de jouer bon il y a
pas grand chose ici
quelque chose comme ça même les finales
sont quand même pas parce que certes tu
vas voir le cavalier en D4 alors
admettons on va montrer web 5 tu fais
tour 1 admettons Tour Eiffel ou l'autre
ta mère
dame prend pour prendre juste pour
montrer et dès que tu vas en F3 D4 avec
ton kg j'ai mon fou qui va venir 4 aussi
donc bon ça ça me semble assez équilibré
non je sais pas ce que tu en penses oui
bien sûr c'est certain ouais on voit
qu'il y a le problème un pion A4 les
pions de reculent pas on n'aime pas trop
qui sont à 4 ce pion parce qu'il y a un
petit peu là
pour même l'option B2 qui a arrêté du
coup etc
oui bon de toute façon en plus c'est pas
trop le style de position qu'un
factionne
ergy puisque il aime bien
et du coup il s'est fait un petit peu
enfin il a été pris à son propre piège à
enfin son sa préparation théorique
n'était pas non plus extraordinaire en
tout cas on voit pas des problèmes qu'il
a pu qui a pu poser un TT de très
sceptique quand tu as vu le coup moi
j'attendais de voir mais c'est vrai que
ce C3 suivi de F4 on se dit peut-être 5
mais il y a très vite F6 et du coup déjà
c'est peut-être égal
probablement il a rien fait
d'extraordinaire c'est pour ça que ça
prépare et peut-être pas extraordinaire
je sais pas il faut regarder toujours
pareil faut regarder avec un ordi et
puis bien sûr
canaliser et puis voir si c'est vraiment
dangereux mais bon moi il aurait fallu
réussir à prendre et à faire carrer les
deux clips on n'a jamais le temps il y a
des fois si il y a des T5 ok c'est un
petit peu davantage d'un coup comme C3
c'est que c'est une tellement mauvaise
tête que tu es sûr de surprendre
exactement c'est le seul point positif à
part ça j'en vois pas il y a une
dernière partie après on va revenir
quand même merci pour ton commentaire
sympa et oui éteindre on dit tu es dans
l'œuf mais ça marche aussi
ça a été très très difficile alors
Prague max Zodio
alors une offre
on regarde ce qui nous a fait il nous a
gâté tiens H3 E5 ninder donc la position
de départ oui donc alors la nage d'or
donc cher à Maxime vacheragrave voilà H3
j'ai regardé il y a pas longtemps en
plus E5 alors là déjà
trois marginal il y a une partie récente
donc c'est Bacro Étienne contre
Jean-Noël Rif une partie que j'ai
regardé parce qu'il y a des idées de
cavalier H4 qu'on peut voir aussi
certaines de certaines lignes ok
pourquoi pas donc dame c'est 7 et là
cavalière de là c'est complètement
délirant je connais pas du tout cette
idée tu connais
non non mais je comprends par contre
c'est génial comprendre c'est facile on
veut taper le cavalier pour la case
exactement le fou c'est quand même beau
alors ce genre de
très très très drôle et donc ouais comme
tu l'as dit dans ce genre de structure
vraiment tout tourne autour de du
contrôle de la case des 5 et d'ailleurs
d'AMC 7 était un coup pour contrôler
plus ou moins à caisse des 5 pourquoi
parce qu'on empêche tous ces quatre et
ensuite le fou en ces quatre contre le
Ray très bien la case des 5 donc dame C7
a vraiment pour utilité de de d'empêcher
fousser 4 et là H2 ouais rendu possible
G4 et pourquoi pas ça a l'air bon très
très belle très très classe
d'autant plus que elle est rare enfin
moi je ne l'ai jamais vu en tout cas
Laurent on voit la manœuvre cavalier F1
cavaliers de cavaliers G4 dans les
Indiens en premier ce qui n'a rien à
voir du tout ici et on a l'impression
que maintenant
bien sûr espagnol mais c'est vrai que là
effectivement au septième coup ça paraît
assez incroyable donc le centre et le
centre est fermé donc on peut se
permettre ce genre de choses
3 oui plus standard d'ailleurs mais pas
avec un passage en H2 normalement il
viendrait de là par exemple mais c'est
vrai que là c'est fou cavalier je le
préfet G4 et ça a été joué c'est ça qui
est rigolo quand il met 17 cavalier G4
en même temps c'est l'idée et du coup si
on nous prend on prend sans doute de h1
et on a les G5 voilà j'ai 5 le pion H7
faibles et un bon contrôle de la caisse
des 5 donc il y a pas de raison de
prendre ici avec les noirs et je vous
paie 5 surtout pas prendre
et on fait cavalier E3 et ça y est on a
trouvé notre petite case et un pressing
ça fait penser aux structures de
chasnikov avec des 6 E5 de toute façon
il y a pas eu un G 1 F6 mais on
travaille sur ces cases là donc du coup
c'est assez normal cavalier B6 parce que
on se fait travailler sur cette case là
on cherche à la contrôler la gloire
aussi puis après faut baisser tout aussi
hein
du coup je préfère après cavalière
là là c'est pas je trouve pas que les
blancs soient spécialement bien
ça va c'est une nageur normal c'est
normal ouais enfin ouais ça ressemble à
quelque chose de logique alors tout à
l'heure on a eu un joli petit tour de
passe-passe
je pensais que le fou il irait peut-être
en E2 F3 ça n'a lâché la cassé 4 mais on
contrôle avec le cavalier je le trouvais
mieux en F3 mais ok on va voir comment
il a préféré mettre la dame
ouais
5 clairement donc j'ai 6 logique
cavalier F5 qui était pénible à tolérer
parce qu'on n'a pas envie de donner
notre foot 15 blanche et le cavalier en
F5 à tout moment il peut prendre le 7 ou
simplement maintenir la pression donc
très désagréable tout à fait donc il a
préféré faire G6
et Jessie c'est quand même un petit peu
affaiblissant sur case noire autour du
roi bon bah c'est pas un désert pour
l'instant c'est dur de placer le Phocéen
parce qu'on a envie de garder notre
cavalier E3 bon pour contre la case il
faut pas oublier qu'un des plans noirs
standard dans ce genre de sicilienne bah
c'est de jouer des 5 parce que le pion
arrière et ben c'est changerait on
aurait plus vraiment de problème
donc cavalier fd7 a été a été joué je
pensais que le coût normal c'était
plutôt petit rock ici le rang pour un
jour jouer pour des 5 un joueur de
sicilienne régulier avec les notes je
sais qu'avec les blancs tu es un joueur
tu as beau joueur de D4
j'ai joué pendant longtemps là je
choisis coffre d'accord donc tu as ah
oui donc tu as joué ces positions un
petit peu ouais d'accord moi ça c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose mais non
moi je me permets pas trop de
commentaires ou de critiquer les coûts
parce que enfin
tellement toujours été mauvais avec les
blancs dans ces sicilienne que tu vois
c'est pour ça
moi je dis j'avais envie de jouer juste
petit rock ça me semblait plus normal
parce que le cavalier F6 tu vois non je
sais pas de je sais pas Laurent de ce
que je comprends de comment j'aurais
joué je dis pas que le coup est
particulièrement mauvais non mais tu
vois moi j'ai mis j'ai joué 25 ans
exclusivement que 4 les 25 premières
années de ma vie donc c'était hier 2-3
ans j'ai joué que 4 et après je me suis
mis à D4 mais c'est vrai que les
siciliennes au final je me suis rendu
compte que tard que je suis ici en fait
je il y avait un truc qui me manquait
voilà c'était pas mon c'était pas mon
c'était moins fort dans d'autres
positions donc voilà je travaille pas
assez je m'étais pas je sentais pas les
les choses trop dynamiques je sais pas
il y avait il y avait toujours un défaut
donc pour ça j'ai changé kfd7 food 2
donc ça l'idée passer le cavalier en C5
c'est ça qui nous montre ouais pour moi
c'est un mauvais coup mais franchement
je me permettrai pas c'est moi qui
comprend pas là pour le coup
non je sais pas moi je trouve que c'est
pas non j'aimais pas indirectement je
crois que c'était normal mais bon après
c'est facile à dire O2 donc il a gardé
il a gardé il faut
et attention maintenant si tu fais petit
rock
admettons
si tu prends du pion je reprends du pion
tu vas bouger le fouet à F6 et dame G3
et compagnie et c'est hyper dangereux
on va après pouvoir parce que mater ou
récupérer du matos bon si si j'avais
intéressant mais ouais le public le
public acclame veut aller voir Magnus
allez on va voir
la Coupe d'Europe des Clubs
je sais pas de quoi tu me parles le
Vince
en fait c'est plus tard quoi c'est
traditionnellement la Coupe d'Europe des
clubs et en octobre tous les ans il y a
Coupe d'Europe des Clubs voilà descart
c'est le coup des poules mouillées
Fisher
[Musique]
on retourne voir ma news on avait arrêté
notre analyse dans cette position où
Laurent voulait jouer ou à deux vous
rappeler que je voulais jouer des 5
évidemment il y a eu fou ah non D5 bien
joué donc D5 x 2 trop fins Laurent
toujours trop fin pour Magnus voilà
quelle mauvaise foi je savais que ça
allait te faire réagir incroyable vous
pouvez pas rester sans réponse par
rapport à ça donc on prend des cavalier
prend des c'est normal c'était l'idée
thématique on avait dit fausse mouiller
avec la paire de fou faut y aller sinon
on va rester avec un pion fixé au centre
et on va morfler donc vous aussi le jeu
ici des Noirs c'est d'égaliser la
position et de repiquer un fou pour
égaliser la pose d'apprendre fou prendre
à me prendre on est proche de l'égalité
mais en règle générale si les dames
s'échangent on pourrait avoir un petit
pressing avec le fou
dans les finales Laurent c'est
c'est Mathieu qui expliquait je l'ai
entendu dire ça dans un stream avec
Stéphane Mathieu cornette quand elle
était intervenu qu'il y a un principe
que je connaissais absolument pas il a
évoqué c'était très pédagogique le
principe des trois colonnes ouvertes
ça laisse passer c'est ça tu es d'accord
j'ai jamais j'avais jamais réfléchi en
ce terme effectivement je suis comme toi
mais c'est vrai que Fisher a gagné des
parties assez
il a prouvé que le fou était plus fort
que le cavalier dans les positions
regarde comme ça oui il faut qu'il y ait
des pions des deux côtés sur les deux
ailes moi c'est ça on a vu plusieurs
exemples même de partie moderne ou le
fou gagne quasiment tout le temps il y a
quelques nuls des très belles parties
mais j'avais jamais pensé à théoriser ce
principe là avec l'histoire des trois
colonnes et j'ai trouvé sympa parce que
ça peut donner un petit guide aussi
surtout quand en France on est quand
même pas le pays où on a le plus étudié
les finales en Bretagne on n'est pas la
région où on a le plus et puis il y a
les finales donc je me suis dit tiens
c'est pas mal c'est pas bête de le
théoriser comme ça j'ai trouvé que
c'était sympa voilà donc en tout cas une
réflexion intéressante évidemment comme
tout des théories il va y avoir des
exceptions mais effectivement quand on y
réfléchit comme ça ça a l'air plutôt
juste oui c'était pas bête du tout de le
dire comme ça ça il y a du passage pour
le roi donc ça favorise le fait qu'on
puisse rentrer avec notre droit en
s'appuyant sur la force de notre faute
donc pour C1 tours C8 bon c'est
c'est plutôt plat comme position mais
Magnus Excel Laurent dans ses positions
alors justement pour toi Magnus tu as
l'habitude même de jouer contre lui je
suis sûr que vous faites plaisir aussi
on joue plus maintenant
c'est trop dur
pour moi
j'ai vieilli mais du coup sa qualité sa
qualité principale parce qu'en fait
c'est tout faire déjà ok mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il fait beaucoup de
différence à ce niveau là donc on parle
vraiment du top 10 mondial sur le le
niveau technique avec
des choses presque simples mais qu'il
fait avec une précision chirurgicale
enfin c'est
pour moi
sa principale qualité c'est l'intuition
tu vois il y a il va t'expliquer il faut
mettre la dame par là le parent tu vois
il sait pas trop expliqué pourquoi mais
il le sent et tu regardes avec leur dire
en fait c'est ça qu'il faut faire donc
c'est il a une formidable
formidable goût de tu vois de l'harmonie
tu vois c'est toujours très tu vois il y
a toujours beaucoup d'harmonie dans les
positions de Magnus donc voilà
typiquement dans ce genre de position tu
vois il faut se sentir où les pièces
vont aller ou les pions vont aller aussi
voilà les pions qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec les pions à la dame est-ce qu'on y
touche on y touche pas quel pion on
touche à l'endroit bon là ça a l'air
plus ou moins réglé parce que si on
touche le pion G on va faire G3 ça fait
bien les cases blanches autour du roi on
a le fond de te voir donc ça n'irait pas
probablement on va faire H3 pour se
créer la petite case
mais voilà il a un sens de l'harmonique
et normalement incroyable et c'est vrai
que dans ces positions assez plates ou
c'est lui un peu qui a joué ses
positions jusqu'au bout et il a commencé
à gagner quelques-unes contre
l'émergement mais contre Wesley
attention on trouve Wesley
je me rappelle pas de partie gagner
comme ça contre Wesley il est quand même
il est très dur aussi et regardez il
échange tout ouais il a pas peur il joue
dans ma cave il met le cavalier mvl le
fameux
Laurent nous a fait réviser ma technique
de la petite porte pour éviter le match
du couloir en plus donc profitez-en ceux
qui ont du mal à le mettre du couloir
voilà mais Magnus a continué de manière
un peu plus piquante avec
il a pas encore fait la porte mais ça va
venir ça il faut qu'il fasse sa petite
porte bah oui c'est bizarre qu'il est
pas fait celle-là je fais du coup alors
Cavalia 5 d'un mètre 4 alors d'un F4 bon
pourquoi comment peut-être pour jouer un
petit tour ces 7 quand même pour
travailler sur la colonne mais en fait
wesleo il dit bon et c'est comme dirait
yoshif c'est le bon tandem le tandem
cavalier travaille bien sur les deux
couleurs donc c'est assez légitime de
garder dame cavaliers avec des Noirs
alors le cavalier ouais c'est ce que dit
effectivement le cavalier loin quand
même hein
cette position et on pourrait peut-être
être très ouverte exactement dame j'ai
trois H4 bon ben du coup on fait le
grand on fait pas H3 on fait H4 allez
c'est parti allez H4 tu fais plus tu
fais la grande porte en fait la grande
porte la grande porte pour Laurent parce
qu'il veut essayer de faire un truc
comme ça c'est ça Laurent ouais et quand
tu vas arriver là bon je vais faire un
schiste par exemple peut-être que je
fais H5 avant mais non je pense que je
vais et du coup après ça sera quoi ton
idée une fois pour pour passer pour ah
oui tu vas peut-être jouer pour mettre
une batterie en place me faire faire F6
je vais essayer de te créer il faut que
tout à fait non je veux jamais gagner
hein on va faire des affaiblissements je
crois je crois que globalement on va
faire nuit mais là
est-ce que tu penses que Magnus il est
croit vraiment en fait il pense pas sa
question à ces termes il joue et on
verra bien
le problème de Magnus là c'est qu'il a
pas tellement de
qu'est-ce qu'il avait comme choix en
fait parce que s'il faisait pas des
seins comme on l'a expliqué tout à
l'heure tôt ou tard alors en jouant le
très subtil X à deux qu'il a raté quand
même dommage tu lui diras ou sans le
jouet au sein de jouer de toute façon
regarde c'était quoi ces choix après
faut si tu vois quand même un chiffre
foncé donc je pense qu'il est pas
content de ce qui se passe il s'est un
peu fait attraper dans le dans le début
le problème c'est que c'est très bien
préparé donc tout ça j'imagine
[Musique]
ce qui s'est passé dans l'ouverture
parce que il a
assez vite en fait c'est arrivé cette
position il a pas pu faire grand chose
comme tu le dis il était obligé de jouer
12 D5 à partir de là
exactement
je vois pas du tout où Wesley en train
de en train de la perdre très
honnêtement on verra est-ce qu'il va me
faire mentir je le souhaite moi je suis
toujours j'aimerais bien
apprendre quelque chose et un travail
dans cette position sera assez
extraordinaire pas du tout moi j'ai
juste envie que ma news gagnent c'est
très primaire pour le truc tu vois c'est
je regarde le truc en espérant Magnus
gagne si on apprend rien
ça me dérange pas alors on va on va
regarder moi je te propose d'aller voir
guyriad où cette Europe la partie des
leaders et ensuite de faire un léger
break et Monsieur Nossay SFR qui dit
bonjour monsieur terrier monsieur
freystinet dis-donc nous appelle
monsieur aujourd'hui un plaisir de voir
un infiltrant chez vous avez vu comment
tu es sur 24 il faut le dire et
maintenant on est sur une sorte lol et
ben non pas lol parce qu'en fait c'est
pareil et il y a pas déjà il y a pas
d'exclusivité et dozio chass24 groupe
les Magnus et Chess.com sont
une seule entité à partir de ça fait
quelques mois déjà donc voilà pour les
précisions donc ne soyez pas surpris en
fait
on a dit que c'était quand même très
compliqué parce qu'il y avait aussi
quelques trous dans la position noire au
niveau du sang donc on pouvait pas
lancer les pions n'importe comment toi
tu voulais jouer fous aussi pour garder
le
cavalier C6
mais j'aurais plutôt regarder en premier
faut aussi mauvaise pioche Laurent mais
incroyable
c'est l'essentiel on fait des petites
analyses de surface on n'avait pas on
n'a pas le coup à jouer les deux étaient
complètement jouable il faut aussi du
coup faut prendre et finalement tu nous
as signé cette thématique où les blancs
plutôt que de partir à l'attaque parce
que ils seront un petit peu en retard il
y a quand même les B5 qui vont être
intéressants et arriver vite ils ont
plutôt opté dans cette position pour
dame des 6 et la petite finale sans
risque véritable pour
pour les blancs structure très saine
et on est parti maintenant pour
pour un travail bon
4 essensuré sur le bah alors il faut le
décention allez-y s'il vous plaît les
modérateurs
quand même mais
je sais pas est-ce que est-ce que mvl on
peut on peut le revoir dans le top 10 en
2023 oui bien sûr ça fait un classeur
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il le sera une autre histoire
ils veulent tous on voit qu'il y a tous
les petits jeunes qui arrivent
il y a les moins jeunes comme guéri et
compagnie qui sont ultra costauds quand
même bon voilà donc c'est pas facile
aujourd'hui d'être dans le top 10 très
clairement mais il a le talent pour faut
rappeler quand même que dans les
récentes tournois des des candidats et
il a il a été très dangereux donc il
peut il peut quand même faire de très
très belles choses il n'est pas loin de
là tout à fait pour être très honnête si
vous demandez est-ce que mvl va être
champion du monde moi je dirais que
c'est très peu probable c'est pas
impossible si est-ce qu'il va revenir
dans le top 10 mondial je dirais que
c'est très probable
c'est un monde un monde incroyable
d'écart oui bien sûr
cette retraite en fait en tout cas des
vaches un peu du monde ça doit quand
même donner des idées tu vois déjà ouais
tous en fait la problématique c'est que
le tronc des candidats ça reste un
tournoi extrêmement difficile à gagner
il y a personne qui a le lead à part
Magnus pour le gagner à coup sûr enfin
c'est hyper chaud quoi
alors on va voir cette finale en fait
qui est assez qui est assez égale au
final
c'est pas mal harpadello il est bon et
on ne saluer
ça quand même
alors vas-y B4 et qu'est-ce qu'on a
alors effectivement on a joué cette
petite finale et on a il a voulu
contrôler la case des 5 à 120 enfin
reprenant du pion F en E6 alors ça avait
l'avantage dans le milieu de jeu de
contrôler la case D5 mais en finale
c'est vrai que ça ça crée un îlot de
pions supplémentaire mais est-ce que
c'est si grave Kevin je crois alors là
c'est le genre de position que je trouve
absolument soporifique et en fait en
plus la jauge indique 00 les joueurs
vont faire nul mais c'est vrai que
je donnerai même un petit plus au noir
dans ce type de position du fait d'avoir
la majorité d'âmes le roi qui va arriver
au centre après comme j'ai mon pion
aussi c'est effectivement bah c'est
l'équilibre ça me paraît très difficile
de venir gagner en force le pion aussi
on va regarder les couilles là il va
mettre ok le roi aussi et oui on monte
le roi dans les finales évidemment on va
essayer de faire pareil ouais c'est
ah attention attention il y a une
posture quand même tu vois sur B6 tu
commences à créer des salariés 5 tout ça
je fais que un petit coup de cahier des
cinq d'abord peut-être 3b5 ensuite au
roi B5 d'abord je sais pas qu'est-ce que
tu joues là peut-être que ce coup de
cavalier c'est 5 était pas forcément
hyper inspiré on pouvait peut-être jouer
cavalier B6 pour contrôler la position
c'était quoi
ce que je pouvais pas créer une barrière
moi aussi je suis un ambitieux je veux
jouer à 5 B5 ou B5 d'abord mais je crois
que ça marche très bien tu vois c'est
trois
B5 par exemple
mais à 5 il y a cahier des 5 qui me gêne
là c'est quoi ce cavalier à 6 le bon co
je pense que c'est même que BD5 un truc
simple comme ça tu vois ou tu prends
prends je menace d'aller en SSL je
menace 3 BK
attention
on te rappelle que les pions de reculent
pas
petite référence à ce que tu as dit tout
à l'heure donc fais attention Laurent on
ne donc un 5 plutôt moi je pensais que
tu m'écoutais pas du tout mais en fait
aussi à fond surtout en finale et
surtout en finale je peux te dire que tu
sais bien à l'école de bretonne
OK et menace ouais ok si on voit B5 et
tu dois repartir je pense tu as vu c'est
quand même beau hein de défendre cette
finale comme ça avec cavalière de
manière très pratique pour
bon il va pas je pense qu'il va se
passer nul bon de toute façon
il y a quand même plus de problèmes que
je pensais hein
et puis attention guérir technique très
fine donc on va faire un petit break mon
cher Kevin parce qu'il y a besoin la
prod et nous aussi on a besoin donc ça
tombe bien c'est très très bien donc on
vous retrouve
l'instant dans un petit instant avec
grand plaisir pour la suite de cette
ronde qui s'annonce vraiment
intéressantes et techniques et
techniques alors qu'on peut vous dire
que Fabiana carwana et Leonard rognan
ont déjà fait nul on vous dit à tout de
suite à très très bientôt à tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour cette onzième rang du
ça y est on a notre fond bleu on est
hyper bien alors en techniquement on est
au top et du coup on était sur cette
petite finale qui me faisait pas rêver
mais on a regardé juste avant la pose
qu'il y avait potentiellement des petits
soucis Laurent il faut faire attention
avec les Noirs est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
ici faire roi B5 avec des menaces de KS
et 5 des choses comme ça on peut
travailler en tout cas Laurent toi qui
une expérience dans ce genre de position
un peu technique mine de rien qu'est-ce
que tu en penses est-ce que tu peux
encore avoir une petite pression blanche
ou pas c'est pas impossible mais je
crois que il a pris le parti de patte du
tout touché tu vois je voulais créer une
barrière très haute avec mes pions sur
la 5e rangée et en fait il a il a pris
le parti de pas du tout toucher ses
pions et de créer en fait cette barrière
naturelle avec ses pions à cette B7 en
fait tu touches à rien et sur roi B5 qui
est le coup évidemment assez probable on
reviendrait en 17 et on tient ouais
c'est ça j'espérais j'espérais voir
bouger les pièces parce que tu sais à
l'aveugle
donc on va baisser un carré des 7 on
peut pas essayer de gratouiller un petit
peu caricat cavalier A5 pour essayer de
poser des petits problèmes enfin si on
peut
vas-y alors quel est ces quatre est-ce
que j'ai pas un truc tactique comme
assis échec
et attention attention je vais te faire
reculer
5 et à 5 et là du coup j'ai une belle
barrière
qui se fait pas un filtre comme tout à
l'heure ou c'était un peu plus chaud
OK et du coup un autre essai
ouais là je prends OK et justement je me
demandais quel coup d'attente j'allais
jouer parce que roi F6 tu vois si je
joue un coup droit j'ai l'impression
avec cavalier cavalier D5 il a fait un
tour
elle est très probablement perdante
pareil puisque je peux rester faire roi
des cinq rois des 6 en plus et dès que
tu booster pions de l'aile je vais à
l'aile ça c'est mignon on peut montrer à
regarder des cinq gagnent la partie
puisque même sur Rouen E6 pour éviter
les changes on échange quand même et là
on peut circuler faire perdre des temps
réception là avancer pour aller les
cueillir
on pourrait directement d'ailleurs
vraisemblablement mais bon il y aurait
plein de manières de faire ici mais
c'est pas bon du tout donc ça c'est
mieux déjà comme idée un d'échanger le
Caval peut-être maintenant pour poser un
petit problème pratique dans la position
et dans cette situation malinois doit
faire preuve d'un petit peu de précision
pour faire une belle barrière ouais non
en fait il faut juste attendre cavalier
C8 par exemple voilà ok c'est 8 donc
maintenant ça va être un coup de Cavalo
oula oula il aime pas ici un truc là ça
va pas si facile je peux si j'arrive à
te faire bouger là les lignes ça peut
être est-ce que je peux pas faire un
truc allez je fais un truc plus actif ça
me coûte mais bon soit que j'ai 8
cavalier abscisse soit que G6 pour
menacer cavalier F4 et les mauvais
esprits et vos esprits dans le chat
alors ça rigole pas les pauses mais la
pause là il y avait un problème
technique fallait changer la couleur du
stream pour être raccord avec ton frère
de Tata style alors que j'avais tout
préparé à l'avance en plus c'est ça qui
est frustrant alors tu l'as vu cette
belle scène bleue déjà sur sur mon Obs
quelle tristesse tout ce travail engagé
pour rien quoi c'est vrai mais bien sûr
pardon excuse-moi bien sûr bien sûr je
te l'ai montré en plus je pensais que tu
allais me souvenir pour une fois
terrible alors il a joué quoi il a joué
cahier des trois clés B6 ça répète ou
quoi
ouais c'est la partie roi B5 et c'est à
toi de jouer donc je pense qu'il va
jouer cahier des 7 assez rapidement on
va voir bonjour Laurent est-ce que
parfois vous envisagez de passer à
nouveau la barre des 2700 hello en
arrêtant en arrêtant autant le métier de
secondaire au métier de Macron et non je
suis beaucoup moins optimiste qui
tiennent non non je n'y crois pas une
seule seconde si j'y croyais peut-être
que j'aurais
recommencé à jouer beaucoup plus
régulièrement mais je n'y crois pas
est-ce que parfois vous envisagez de
passer à nouveau la barre des 2450 tu as
pas 2450 hello en arrêtant le badminton
et le foot salle
j'ai 24 46 ça me paraît plus jouable que
la barre des 2700 pour Laurent même si
c'est
un gros la barre des 2500 c'est plus dur
voilà mais pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
comme je disais à l'orange j'aimerais
bien rejoint aux et chaque mais bon
c'est un peu de d'organisation
l'histoire
mais par contre le envie qui manque
l'envie qui manque Laurent beaucoup plus
joué que moi donc je peux comprendre qui
est plus de lassitude Laurent tu disais
c'est c'est combien de parties sur sur
tes 30 années de 30 années de carrière
elle est 3000 donc en moyenne 100 par an
3000 parties classées donc attends j'ai
joué quand même beaucoup de rapides
beaucoup de Blitz non mais c'est surtout
que
je sens que j'ai atteint mon pic a été
atteint il y a une dizaine d'années quoi
voilà donc
je vois pas du tout revenir non
c'est c'est compliqué c'est trop ça me
semble pas réaliste quoi simplement je
comprends voilà les forces en présence
et mon niveau et
ça me semble pas réaliste tout
simplement mais c'est pas très grave
j'arrive à
j'arrive à me
résoudre à ça c'est pas très grave ça me
ça empêche plus de dormir en tout cas
alors
du coup on va aller
[Musique]
un travail des blancs pour venir
gagner le pion B mais ça a coûté le
cavalier c'est à dire qu'il y a un
échange de cavaliers qui était prévu
contre le fou et maintenant cette finale
on en parlait tout à l'heure Laurent et
on avait dit qu'il y aurait sûrement nul
parce que c'est très très difficile de
passer mais là surtout en plus tu perds
le pion
c'est pas pareil encore tomber
vous jetez pas sur les pions le pion G3
alors effectivement il aurait pu le
prendre ça toujours été nul mais d'abord
il protège et le pion G3 n'est pas
défendable et donc ça force les bonnes
arrondian à faire nul bon bah c'est
toujours compliqué à ces deux joueurs
qui se connaissent très bien si ça se
trouve il dîne ensemble depuis deux
semaines
bon c'est dur de se faire mal quoi voilà
on va pas leur en vouloir c'est la 11e
ronde ils ont pas les voleurs ne peut
pas gagner le tournoi car on a non plus
ils sont en milieu de classement entre
nous c'est dur de trouver la motivation
on va pas leur en vouloir pour cette
partie
alors bien c'est qu'on a beaucoup de
parties donc on n'a jamais le temps de
s'ennuyer exactement on dirait pas de
voir un tour du côté de Magnus quand
même on est parti
pour Magnus c'est dire que ça va être
difficile de gagner hein si il en est à
faire la technique de la petite porte
proposée par Laurent tout à l'heure dire
que non mais regarde et il fait la
grande porte de l'autre côté il fait A4
tu vois et en fait il a décidé donc ça
c'est un signal très clair il a décidé
que il allait
jouer à l'aile dame pourquoi il allait
jouer à la dame
je vais tenter de lui expliquer
peut-être
qui pourrait être une très bonne pièce
mais il a pas d'accroche tu vois sur
l'eldame donc il va être obligé la seule
application il pourrait être protégé en
E6 par exemple mais le problème c'est
possible E6 qui est une cassera
raisonnable à ce moment-là la dame est
un peu délaissé les pions les dames et
donc ça il pourrait devenir faible
imaginons un terme je touche à rien
je fais une défense un peu passive
est-ce que l'idée ça va être de jouer BK
et du coup ici je me fixe en A5 je suis
trop loin du jeu quoi c'est ça
l'histoire aussi
tu vas faire une petite porte toi aussi
tu te moques vas-y joue il faudra faire
une petite porte c'est très clair petite
porte j'aimerais bien faire un truc
comme ça quoi et ouais mais bon le
problème c'est que tu peux pas il y a un
problème
[Musique]
qui commence à réfléchir on voit il a 30
minutes d'avance à la pendule mais bon
c'est pas une position de toute façon où
le temps va jouer un vrai facteur très
clairement
la position est pas si complexe que ça
il y a pas beaucoup de lignes à calculer
il y a juste un plan à faire pour les
noirs et là c'est l'heure de la dernière
la dernière précision la dernière
précision pour pas souffrir jusqu'à 21h
ce soir donc Wesley il est au courant de
tout ça bien évidemment il connaît
Magnus il respecte énormément Magnus et
donc il va il va essayer de chercher le
plus clean
voilà pour pour essayer de faire nul
mais c'est pas si facile que ça quand
même quoi il faut il faut travailler on
voit que juste la petite différence faut
qu'avale et on travaille c'est bien le
plan juste le petit coin 4 déjà ça donne
plus envie de jouer la position pour
quelque chose ouais je crois alors tu
vois à part des lots qui connaît ma
réputation quand même qui dit Kevin
devant la tech fresque pour le son moi
mon avis c'est le alors je sais pas
comment exactement la régler mais je
sais que quand tu tournes la tête pour
me regarde ne me regarde plus mon cher
crédit il faut que je regarde ouais non
mais regarde pas je pense que le fait
que je sois pas avec le set up habituel
ça ça change des choses je pense
toujours toujours en fait c'est ça qui
est bon en plus au final que ce soit ça
parce que tout était bon bref mais oui
oui c'est un micro accélère donc du coup
c'est un peu plus un peu plus sensible
donc j'ai moins le droit à l'erreur
effectivement on va voir on va voir Ding
van forest parce que c'est carrément qui
s'est calmée je crois
si je vois bien tout ça alors qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé il a choisi quelle case
ah il a fait la vente qu'on a donné hein
donc on vient sur trouver ça dans ma 3D
là et il y a eu ce roi 8 avec le fait de
récupérer la pièce prise des 7 cavalier
prend des 7 ok dame c'est 3
logique initiative noire dame c'est deux
on n'avait pas été jusque-là avec
beaucoup de
beaucoup de pression faut prendre ma
carte d'impro E3 ça récupère du pion
d'un meude change les dames ok tu
reprends B4 grand
Rocket ok on a le fou
mais cette position les Noirs vraiment
d'une dynamisme exactement et une petite
fixation avec G5 de quasiment tous les
droits et assurer la belle case en E5
pour le cavalier sans se faire chasser
ça c'est aussi assez important pour ces
deux je suppose que cavaliero 5 est
quand même le coup
auquel on pense tout de suite
je vois pas de contre-indication à moins
que à trois
à trois et un coup ici donc à 5 non
qu'est-ce que tu voulais jouer d'autre
mais s'il y a trois un peu gênant quand
même
et je dois garder la protection du pion
C4
ouais ce qui est pas c'était pas
exactement le sale-plan
mais d'un autre côté si je protège avec
ma tour en C8 ça va rien changer et ça
enlève la taxe sur le pion sur le pion
H2 donc on a envie quand même
d'immobiliser cette tour encore un peu
plus
c'est peut-être plus facile de
travailler un petit peu avec les blancs
mais on a toujours pour mobiliser cette
tour une problématique quand même donc
il faut est-ce qu'on va jouer H3 ouais
je crois qu'on va faire
H3 quoi mais ça laisse quand même des
bien sûr des choses avec le cavalier à
un moment bon pour l'instant le fournir
on veut jouer pour tourner un peut-être
tour des 4 et au pire des cas sur le
plan que tu as dit on joue à foue F1 et
bon bref on tient on a juste fait des
trous c'est pas effectivement c'est pas
un setup d'attaque mais
ça a l'air raisonnable quand même pour
les Noirs
c'est 5 il faut faire très attention
avec les B3 etc
pourquoi pas
et on peut tenir aussi le pion tout
simplement mais il faut faudra toujours
regarder les B3
ce que ça se fait est-ce qu'on peut
passer aussi avec le roi effectivement
il y a des plans comme ça aussi plus
tard en finale qui peuvent être très
dangereux pour les pour les blancs
parce que notre tour est moins justifiée
ici
elle est moins compliquée que tout à
l'heure cette position mais elle reste
quand même ça reste des équilibré assez
déséquilibré pour être intéressant parce
qu'on pourrait se dire bon c'est final
c'est le matériel égal ça va faire nul
mais en fait c'est pas
une suite rigolote c'est le tour de 8 et
peut-être la tentative H4 et là on
ramener la tour
c'était plutôt bon ok donc du coup
cavalier ça a été joué
alors ça permet quoi par rapport aux
variantes donc à 3
toujours je pense Laurent c'est logique
on va rester sur cette pression pour
mettre la tour en 4 ça me semble normal
après on peut le faire un peu quand on
veut soit 3
enfin je crois d'abord
mais bon
à chaque fois
ouais ouais mais regarde par exemple je
sais pas disons à trois je joue à trois
je tour à 4
h 3 tour D8 tour D1 voilà
c'est ça je crois pas je crois pas que
ça soit un bon deal pour toi
je crois que tous ces 8 est pas mal
parce que tu menaces ces trois du coup
tu menaces C3 il y a 3 peut-être en prie
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on ferait pas
même là
j'ai un peu de chance
je sais pas si vous voulez prendre du
roi mais j'ai ça et ça
c'est sûr je sais pas face à l'air pas
con en tout cas
c'est peut-être pour ça que à 3 est pas
forcément c'est peut-être un peu tôt
peut-être que je peux commencer par H3
et comme ça tu as plus ces idées avec
ces trois
tu vois par exemple typiquement H3 je
joue au lieu de à 3 je joue
et ton cahier des 5 ok des 5 mais je
fais je fais un coudre c'est un par
exemple et tu as plus alors tu as qu'à
aller au 3 du coup
mais voilà typiquement faudrait calculer
tours G2 tours C4 moi ça me fait très
peur
effectivement tu as créé un peu de jeu
mais c'est beaucoup plus compliqué pour
toi de se créer des
un pion passé à l'endroit très compliqué
la finale est très déséquilibrée donc ce
que veut dire Laurence c'est que voilà
il y a encore beaucoup de jeux pour les
deux joueurs même si on voit que la
jauge met 0 0 ça ne veut rien dire
exactement il y a encore beaucoup de
d'espace pour faire pour faire des
erreurs des deux côtés surtout
à l'air je me sens ici globalement avec
ces champions passé à la dame est-ce
qu'on irait pas voir une autre partie
ouais on peut aller voir gamer ça fait
longtemps qu'on l'a pas vu qu'il meurt
avec j'ai l'impression que ça bouge pas
trop c'était un mauvais choix mais bon
quand même pas mal pour les mois
apparemment oui mais moi j'allais dire
que ça c'est plutôt bien passé pour les
noirs qui semblent avoir récupéré un
petit peu d'espace ils sont moins sous
l'emprise à tout à l'heure la structure
c'était C4 et DSi au niveau des pions
ok mais maintenant c'est plutôt le jeu
de pièces qui est supérieur on n'a pas
le B5 pour dégager le cavalier
A5 difficile de trouver des cases pour
pour les pièces noires c'est ça
exactement c'est un peu un peu moins
d'espace finalement les dames on peut
pas jouer B6 B5 parce qu'on donnerait la
Casa 5 ça serait quand même très
embêtant et qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
les Noirs c'est toujours la même
question pas évident et gamer qui est
aussi un bel avantage à la pendule qui
montre que sa position est quand même
plus facile à jouer aussi j'ai
l'impression encore en train de dominer
aujourd'hui mondial c'est la routine
pour lui
après la routine c'est derrière de ne
pas gagner donc je pense qu'il a envie
de de casser la routine exactement mais
c'est pas c'est clairement pas un
problème d'ouverture ou un problème de
milieu de jeu oui domine il domine ses
adversaires avec une régularité qui est
quand même assez bluffante pour un
joueur de cet âge comment continuer ici
alors est-ce que tu as des idées pour
mettre encore plus de pression moi je
jouerai tout EDF
chances sur 10 que je joue ça il y avait
tout
et après j'ai pensé au coup un peu plus
compromettant E4
c'est de la composition ça
E4 alors vas-y analysons l'idée donc bon
voilà j'ai envie de faire ça quoi voilà
c'est très sommaire parce que tout René
tout Redé 8 et je me disais bah
peut-être que après tu joues autour des
deux remarqué ça mais je me suis dit
tiens on va aller la Bretonne la
Bretonne c'est la Bretonne ça tu pousses
puis quand tu repousses tu pousses et tu
bloques bah tu profites aussi bah tu as
un meilleur centre mais c'est pas bête
je pense en plus
j'aime bien
j'aime bien j'aime bien ce coup là alors
cavalier H5 et que c'est moche
c'est bizarre il faut que j'empêche ça
bien sûr
est-ce que tu as une découverte vas-y je
joue avec le feu on aime ça avec le feu
les pièces de jeu ah mais non mais je
joue avec le feu je fais n'importe quoi
en fait je voulais dire cavalier 5 mais
il prend des 6 en fait
je peux pas bouger ça ou ça bouge pas
mais je vois pas d'autres coups de
cavalier H5
quoi d'autre franchement parce que 5 et
une énorme menace hein j'ai pas contente
je regarde mais j'ai pas le droit
peut-être
peut-être ça quand même
mais
il faut regarder là faut pas donner le
pion maintenant puis sur le 5 en plus
faudra vérifier B5 en plus mais il y a
peut-être que 6 on verra mais déjà faut
regarder le 5 cavaliers prend cavalier
prend
je suis pas sûr que ça marche faut
prendre alors c'est pas grave
on se trompe
pas mes pièces je dis aux élèves Laurent
normalement
vous avez quand même les faveurs de
Laurent vous avez le droit tout le temps
de tester en bougeant les pièces mais
bon non parce que sinon il y a le petit
G3 aussi peut-être un pour essayer
attention attention
je suis pas sûr que ça marche hein
tes élèves de ne pas bouger les pièces
moi je dis exactement l'inverse mes
élèves dans tous les sens on fait
n'importe quoi c'est de l'analyse
surtout essayez de jouer le plus mauvais
coup possible comme ça comme ça on teste
tout
non bon bah ça on voit que ça ça marche
pas j'aimerais bien avoir une découverte
vous voyez même tout reprend mais je
donnais tous mes pièces donc c'est pour
ça que tu m'as insisté à le jouer donc
là calmos
à sentir tes pièces sont loin du jeu
il faut donner ouais bon c'est un petit
plus quand même mais bon il y a c'est un
petit plus quand même on est d'accord on
est d'accord non mais le petit G4 le
petit G3 le petit G3 parce que le petit
G3
ne me raconte pas d'histoires vas-y
prends ces trois étranger snap moi ça
dame project 3 ouh là là oh là là ouais
pas contente elle est pas contente elle
va placer j'étais pas sûr que tu arrives
à mettre un feu cinq dommage mais bon il
y aura plus de détails mettre un
cavalier 5 là déjà pour commencer bon ok
c'est trop de ris de toute façon faut
pas jouer comme ça
non là tu cherches alors du coup comment
on fait parce que quand
et alors si je joue bêtement si je
rentre dans des structures espagnoles
après le cash je fais E5 ah bah soit
c'était plus attendu à chaque c'est
quand même intéressant
pour être plus tranquille
mais oui non c'est pas terrible j'aime
bien ton coup de 4 OK
mais E4 cavalier H5 alors c'est que tu
as vu quelque chose pour les blancs
parce que mine de rien j'ai pas trouvé
même si ça j'aime bien cahier tu fais
confiance OK
peut-être un petit coup de tourner quand
même pour poser une question d'abord
mais bien sûr là il faut jouer un peu
pour eux par exemple pour eux j'allais
mettre la tour c'est maintenant on n'a
jamais d'accord sur les retours
H5 donc ouais c'était pour garder l'idée
5 pour l'avoir en réserve mais bon
peut-être de toute façon c'est difficile
de savoir
et clairement il réfléchit à ça qu'il
meurt c'est 4 effectivement 4 j'avais
pas du tout envisagé mais c'est une
belle idée Kevin à mon avis
on essaie de profiter et du coup toi tu
voulais faire au début tout roder parce
que ça se regarde aussi mine de rien et
simplement pour D8 c'est peut-être un
petit coup de tour ouais mais le tour
des deux il y a B5 peut-être à C5 non ma
tour des deux
et je double et on travaille voilà c'est
ça un peu Laurent effectivement ça peut
s'échanger un moment
un ou deux points peut-être cavalier
d'ailleurs c'est des questions à se
poser
ouais mais qui avait le 4 ça se trouve
passer des trucs non je peux juste
prendre
un petit pressing quand même blanc même
dans cette
carte est compromettant même si c'est
une bonne tête il peut jouer ça sans
risque et E4 qui change la position donc
il est obligé de vérifier quoi c'est pas
un désastre c'est pas c'est pas archi
compromettant tu vois ça reste
raisonnable
et il a joué à 4 OK
humeur du lundi on a des bombes pseudo
en ce moment on avait
[Musique]
en même temps humeur du lundi un peu
dans ce registre là
alors nous c'est vrai qu'on faisait plus
je vois si vous êtes sur on est aussi
sur Youtube c'est vrai qu'on était plus
YouTube que twitch tu sais c'est
vraiment c'était ma modernité je crois
qu'il
qui est instauré tout ça tu vois
le militaire et et j'ai les mails
évidemment donc mais c'est vrai que
toujours les pseudos sur twitch j'ai
toujours remarqué que c'était quand même
c'était quelque chose de manière
générale les pseudos sont quand même
assez bizarres très très bon par contre
tu connais discord
je suis dégoûté mais je suis obligé de
te l'avouer quoi parce que j'aurais bien
aimé te dire que j'avais snapchat que je
l'avais depuis hyper longtemps et tout
ça malheureusement
bon c'est pas le cas on continue à le
coup de jouer c'est à 4 qui a été joué
c'est juste moi qui ai
A4
sont-elles définitivement terrain et
tout change tous les deux mois trois
cerises qu'est-ce que je te dise moi on
verra on sait pas rien est enterré
définitivement
red définitif dans ce monde voilà donc
on sait pas
alors A4 et ouais il veut y aller il va
doucement notre ami
mais en cas du coup c'est quoi en fait
j'aime bien mais c'est quoi l'idée c'est
ok je prends de l'espace mais en fait
j'ai poussé comment j'ai pas fait à 5 à
B5 ça veut dire mon ks-4 et si je vais
B5 je donne la casse C5 j'ai
l'impression qu'il considérait que B6 B5
était cavalier à 5 x 8 était peut-être
une main d'accord c'était ça
après peut-être x 3 aussi
[Musique]
comme quoi il y a beaucoup et toute se
tenait objectivement pas 4 c'est un peu
plus long mais il estime que le joueur
noir s'ennuie et on le laisse un peu
s'ennuyer Richard rapporte qui peut être
parfois fantasme en tout cas là une
position sérieuse mais pas si facile que
cela a joué
ouais alors il a commencé
assez mal le tournoi il était à deux
défaites et zéro victoire assez
rapidement il a gagné deux consécutives
ensuite il a forcé nul avec les Blancs
contre les von Aronian et là il joue
très solide on sait pas trop ce qu'il
fait je suis pas sûr que lui-même
sache exactement quelle est la stratégie
mais il la joue en fonction de son
humeur de la journée donc voilà plutôt
parfois solide parfois un grand
casillant à la première partie enfin
voilà Richard il est il est imprévisible
j'ai l'impression même pour lui-même et
il vous faut 8 Richard rapporte ok on va
voir il y a d'autres parties
certainement on va faire un petit tour
avant de revenir évidemment chez les
leaders qu'est-ce qu'on va voir
a volé ta blague à pas de métal ou pas
de métal tu l'as volé mais en tout cas
vous êtes copain de blagues vous avez la
version Chuck Norris mais avec
Jean-Claude Van Damme ça marche aussi
vous regarderez voilà les petites
blagues sont de sortie dans le chat du
coup Florent
on peut avoir que des nuls aujourd'hui
ça serait possible mais
ce serait énorme tu vois
c'est pas impossible on peut vraiment le
seul la partie la plus déséquilibrée au
final c'est par rame contre pragalanda
cette
autant se régaler un petit peu
mais encore c'est quand même pas non
plus tu vois mais c'est très
déséquilibré oui ça il y a pas photo ok
c'est à 4 chacun fait son truc donc avec
les Blancs il a essayé de lancer une
attaque elle a le roi chacun fait son
truc dans son coin ouais c'est ça
veut se venger sur les dames mais une
grosse pression sur le pur B2 si on
prend prend et on joue B3 il y a
toujours la casser C3 en fait on va être
obligé de lâcher quelque chose j'ai
l'impression avec les Blancs oui
exactement en fait les Noirs ont obtenu
beaucoup de choses mais les blancs
veulent la peau du
roi noir
oui et puis il y a quand même des idées
H4 c'est pas ridicule
donc il a pris prix et est-ce qu'on fait
H4 alors ça c'est la grande question
est-ce qu'on prend d'abord en G6 par
exemple et on joue H4 où on fait H4
direct j'en sais rien peut-être que le
motif de défense sera de venir avec la
dame en E5 pour pour tenir les lois
ça tiendrait beaucoup de cases et ça
posera un problème au F5
toute façon je suis pas mécontent de
prendre en G6 parce que ça c'est
attaquant contre un défenseur donc ça ça
reste raisonnable comme échange et puis
tu es quand même pas je sais pas trop de
quoi tu vas reprendre
[Musique]
chapitre 5 avec les noirs avec les
Blancs
la dernière partie elle remonte à quand
c'est assez incroyable en fait quand il
réfléchit parce qu'il joue quand même
aucun contre 5 la plupart du temps ok je
décide aussi mais la plupart du temps il
joue E40 quel était quizz pour le chat
allez le chat de toute façon
ça doit faire un sacré moment j'ai baisé
un petit peu un petit peu un petit peu
oui c'est vrai oh bah c'est pas une
question que je poserai c'était
avant-hier quoi tu vois
non mais attends il faut citer la partie
attends c'est pas les quiz c'est quiz
haut de gamme là 2016 au pif celui qui a
un bon de chasse bas une bonne petite
requête statistique et c'est ok
c'était quasiment ça
le 14 juillet 889 ouais c'est ça quand
on a 2015 ils ont la bonne année mais
ils ont pas la bonne rêve donc la
dernière je le dis puisque personne n'a
trouvé c'est contre ah Nande ah non en
2015 on aurait une chaise qui s'était
mal passé donc imagine depuis 2015 il a
pas perdu avec les noirs sur E40
principal à part hommage championnat du
monde contre Kawana où il a joué
hier il a des bons secondaires non ça
c'est vrai sur le sujet de 4 5 il est
rarement mal après le début franchement
ça se passe bien mais après c'est vrai
que tu vois tu lui mets une position ok
bon de toute façon elle est ordinateurs
d'aujourd'hui c'est quand même pas très
compliqué de trouver une position
jouable et c'est vrai qu'après il joue
avec une précision on l'a vu qu'on est
pas bien chier hommage champion
c'était infernal enchanté que d'ailleurs
c'était à mon avis selon moi c'est un
mauvais choix n'est pas bien chier de
jouer ce genre de position technique
après un moment une fois dans la partie
cheval du monde c'est C4 que nepomatchi
pouvait jouer poser un petit problème
ça faisait penser à une position où il y
avait tu vois je l'assise spontanément
parce que c'est la seule fois où je me
suis tiens il y a peut-être un truc
quand même c'est bizarre qui le fasse
parce que ça veut dire vraiment normal
je crois que je m'étais posé la question
tiens pourquoi il joue pas ça et du coup
bon si on voit c'est que je me dis que
le mec doit avoir quoi c'est un peu ça
le truc alors c'est que normalement
la seule fois où il était un peu en
danger sur sur 4,5 on t'imagines sur ce
quand même pas mal de partir en fait
finalement on est pas bien chez elle
c'est seule chance de gagner
véritablement des parties ça a été avec
les Noirs oui bien sûr
donc peut-être pas un bon choix mais
après c'est toujours facile moi je dis
c'est pas une fois mais qu'est-ce qu'il
faut jouer après quand on est dans le
dans le cœur du truc je sais que c'est
pas c'est pas toujours évident mais
quand même tiens c'est intéressant d'y
revenir parce que je trouvais que
nepomatchi dans le début de match de
championnat du monde jouer aussi
extrêmement bien enfin c'était mon
sentiment il y a eu ce C4 raté et après
il s'est complètement délité après
l'énorme partie le pressing un peu
comment un sportif qui aurait pris un
gros coup au moral et après c'était plus
même joueur fin après c'était enfin
quand il commence à faire ses grosses
boulettes c'était le niveau d'un petit
grand maître on va dire c'était vraiment
pas fou c'est vraiment le sentiment que
j'ai eu Laurent mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il jouait très bien dans le début de
match et vous votre sentiment justement
ouais c'est un début de match ça sent on
n'a pas eu si tu veux les matchs
champion du monde malheureusement à part
le premier contre à Nantes on n'a jamais
Manu ça jamais très très bien joué dans
les débuts de match il y a jamais pris
l'ascendant très rapidement même contre
un an d'acheter Nike a été son autre
succès très large avec trois points
d'avance les quatre premières parties
ont été nul
donc c'est rare qui commence très bien
donc il y a pas il y a pas trop
d'inquiétude c'est vrai que nepo avec
très bien réagi tu as raison dans la
deuxième partie notamment enfin c'est
une idée un petit peu nouvelle va être
même très nouvelle où on espérait
vraiment qui qui agissent moins bien il
avait sur échiquier trouver d'excellents
coups la quatrième partie connaissait
exactement et c'est vrai que ouais il
jouait bien le début de match c'est sûr
c'est sûr et après ouais cette sixième
partie qui
n'a complètement
ça la février c'était incroyable parce
que justement la force de ces joueurs là
donc de Magnus mais aussi des joueurs de
de la grosse élite c'est normalement de
savoir à peu près digérer quand même une
défaite même si elle était extrêmement
difficile
des gros défauts qu'il a c'est-à-dire
d'équiper une partie il explose il
explose en vol et d'ailleurs c'est là où
il a eu cette chance dans les premiers
candidats où il perd la dernière ronde
contre Maxime et le tournoi alors
effectivement il n'y a pas c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas du fait de
évidemment de dépôt il y avait cette
pandémie il y avait en fait elle existe
toujours mais plus ou moins et voilà le
tournoi s'arrête et pour lui c'est
extraordinaire pour lui c'est vraiment
c'est le principal gagnant et d'ailleurs
c'était facilement prévisible
ça c'est le joueur que ça rangeait le
plus parce qu'il réagit très mal au
défaite après les gens disent que ça
s'amélioré bah non en fait au dernier
candidat il a pas perdu donc en fait on
en sait rien attendre qu'il perdent une
partie qu'on Ding
si ça arrive si par la première partie
qu'on dit à mon avis il a perdu le match
voilà j'annonce le siding marque le
premier point je vois pas n'est pas
revenir je pense pas qu'il est le je
pense qu'à 30 ans c'est trop tard tu
changes plus c'est fini moi j'imagine il
fait en plus qui sont très suivis les
mecs j'imagine que ça enfin ils ont dû
en discuter forcément ouais mais tu vois
il a il a fait aucun travail sur ça il
avait dit j'ai fait beaucoup de travail
sur ça tu parles il a perdu une partie
après il a perdu deux ou trois
consécutifs je sais pas si c'était même
terminé c'était un match à 14 parties ça
se terminait à la 11e donc il y a trois
parties qui n'ont pas été jouées pour
moi c'est un grand plaisir j'étais en
Thaïlande il faisait beau on va passer
une semaine de vacances je veux dire
c'était bien
franchement c'était c'était sympathique
merci Yann si tu nous regardes
et
il a complètement effectivement comme tu
le dis alors grand-mère moyen je sais
pas mais disons
je le exceptionnel au début et du coup
voilà je pense que c'était vrai et après
il était à côté de ses pompes
complètement enfin je veux dire les
fautes c'était
[Musique]
ouais c'était un digne de ce qu'il est
réellement quoi
ouais non je suis d'accord c'est pas en
tout cas je sais pas niveau grand maître
moyen mais en tout cas c'était pas digne
d'un challenger au titre mondial ça
c'est sûr
parce que je trouve que c'est un joueur
exceptionnel en plus indépendamment de
ça en plus il joue on voit qu'il peut
jouer une à toute vitesse avec un niveau
de jeu hyper qualitatif aussi il fait
des ouais mais il fait des coups un
petit peu il a pas gommé ses défauts oui
franchement il a pas gommé ses défauts
alors il y a un choix français qui est
qui lui ressemble dans dans une moindre
mesure hein mais c'est Jean-Noël rive
qui me fait penser un petit peu à népot
dans sa gestion qu'on les 22 23 tu vois
il peut il peut les éclater et peut
aussi faire un gros blender en un coup
moi je trouve que hygiène et nepo et je
trouvais que c'était assez marrant bon
en tout cas moi je suis Pau je suis team
Ding enfin je suis team Ding pas je suis
pour Ding moi je pense que le dépôt il a
pas il a pas le niveau d'un champion du
monde digne plus voilà c'est mon avis on
verra tout ça les ouvertures moi je
crois que nepo il va pas changer il va
jouer le 4 il va juste en espagnol c'est
aussi un problème qu'ils avaient
c'est-à-dire qu'on avait prévu
exactement ce qu'ils allaient faire ils
sont pas très karakin pareil
réussi ils sont très classiques très il
reste dans les clous en plus avec son
équipe tu vois ils étaient potes qui les
cons il a que des joueurs archi bien sûr
pas lui dire de changer un truc il faut
que je la vérité et je pense pas que il
y a un moment où je pense pas que ça
soit une très bonne idée donc moi je
pense qu'il a pas changé contreding donc
il va jouer E4 ça sera des Espagnols en
voiture voilà Ding je vois bien aller
sur le 4 et des pétroles et ce genre de
truc on verra
bon on avait à moitié l'idée de la
position il a joué F français h pour G6
il a trouvé F4
qui est très mauvais d'après la jauge
d'après la jauge au niveau pratique je
trouve que c'est hyper intéressant parce
que c'est la même idée F5 et tu
ouvres ta tour peut-être c'est très
mauvais mais franchement ça pose quand
même quelques soucis pratique alors
est-ce qu'on pourrait faire cavalier
prend B2 et ton truc F5 dame C6 par
exemple ce qu'on peut quand même jouer à
mieux encore
on voyait qu'il y avait la diagonale
ouverte voilà c'est bien c'est l'idée de
France de rangée
il va lui faire F5 je le connais moi
bien sûr bravo Laurent et oui t'empêche
F5 du coup et dame G3 seuls complètement
oublié je pense que l'idée de d'activer
la Tour Eiffel elle est sympa mais si au
final je l'active pas je l'ai dans le
baba Laurent je vais prendre
là
ça va bien avec le caramel ça ça vient
et le caramel dames j'ai trop honte B2
alors moi je suis
j'aime bien pinailler donc sur dame j'ai
trois je commençais à regarder
bien sûr changer fou mais ça ça va venir
plus tard de toute façon
on pourra le faire je vérifié fois cinq
d'ailleurs tu peux jouer mais j'ai trois
jouets et qui prend B2 blitzer papa dans
le regardant droit dans les yeux oui il
y a une ambiance quand même
et lui a dit je pense que je peux me
lever maintenant hop et il est là ah
c'est pas vanner voilà et le petit
Prague là le protéger de tout aussi
voilà et bien sûr pour ceux qui se
demandent un dame C3 attaque G7 attaque
B2 mais il faut F6 et dommage ça ne
fonctionne pas pas loin ça va pas deux
choses cramiques a battu Carlsen côté
blanc à Steve Wenger en 2017 j'ai bon
pour le quiz mais je pense pas que
c'était une partie longue mon cher à
part des lots
par contre il voulait gagner la tasse
comme dédicacée c'était comme ça mais
j'attends à Vanessa elle peut si elle
peut me montrer là je voulais montrer
donc du coup ça serait vraiment bien
chaise 24 mais je veux bien je veux bien
peut-être que Robin side si un moment il
apparaît dans dans le chat
il pourra faire quelque chose pour moi
il est beau mais j'avais plus hein
collector quand même parce que là
franchement
et à côté collector qui est arrivé pour
chaise 24 Kevin et il y a une belle
réelle parce que
je me suis trompé alors tu vois j'avais
fait un faux quiz c'est génial c'est
énorme c'est énorme en plus tu es en
train de te faire réfuter parce qu'elle
gère l'eau salut à toi Angelo
c'est génial c'est génial
comme comme elle gérait l'eau il a
confirmé
il mériterait aussi un meuble du coup
le
il a déjà eu beaucoup de sangliers
de Me gonferme c'est fermé j'ai fait
confiance à Frédéric mais c'est un mec
chasse.com hein tu vois du coup c'est
corpo
si ça me coûte rien tout va bien je sais
pas tu verras avec Robinson
moi c'est pas mon histoire en fait alors
c'est de la faute de ton quiz d'ailleurs
c'est normal que c'est moi qui ai lancé
ça ouais
c'est normal en plus j'ai même pas la
réponse du quiz c'est même pas sûr de ta
question en fait enfin vraiment tout est
à côté non le pire c'est que j'étais
complètement sûr de la réponse mais je
me suis trompé je me suis montré mais ça
arrive hein alors
on est ici me connaît Kevin t'inquiète
pas il faut que ça donne une image on se
connaît Kevin on se connait depuis 30
ans voilà
on sait même plus depuis qu'on se
connaît tellement Squad depuis longtemps
un petit milieu hein c'est un petit
milieu les échecs français on a eu
l'occasion de se voir en tournant après
c'est un petit milieu mais on s'entend
plus ou moins bien avec les gens on a
plus ou moins d'affinités je crois qu'on
peut dire que tous les deux on a aucune
affinité
mais d'ailleurs objectivement dans dans
les dans le dans les joueurs français il
y a quand même une bonne entente
globalement Laurent je sais pas si tu es
d'accord avec ça mais moi j'ai plutôt
cette impression là
il y a pas trop d'histoires il y a pas
trop d'histoires comme il y a eu par le
passé par exemple au National etc il y a
pas trop d'histoires les joueurs se
battaient voilà je te vois bien faire un
peu de chaise boxing toi alors c'est pas
ça
d'accord j'espère que ce sera relayé
j'espère que
la proposition est sur la table depuis
de nombreuses heures d'accord alors
on va voir on va voir Magnus et guéri
alors on va guéri d'abord peut-être
alors
ok avec plaisir et ben ils ont fait
match nul ils ont fait match nul c'est
pas la breaking news alors donc on
voulait faire ça on disait qu'on avait
un petit pressing et en fait apparemment
de rien du tout il a joué G5
et sur G3 il va juger il continue
tu passes pas belle barrière de Abdou sa
torov très très bons résultats pour
évidemment Abdou ça torov qui garde sa
position de tête avec au un demi point
d'avant c'est un très bon résultat
est-ce que Magnus Carlsen va rejoindre
anis guéri en deuxième position c'est la
question et se rapprocher un demi point
se rapprocher dangereusement de de la
douce atrophe
oui et puis on peut dire comme tu
l'avais dit au départ donc à un moment
on a essayé de faire une barrière haute
ça a pas marché il a laissé ses pions à
cette B7
activer le roi et ça passe pas tout
simplement on va pas faire un 4 à 5 à 6
pour pour démonter les pions puisqu'on
on y laissera des plumes cavalier C4
cavaliers à 5 c'est pas facile à mettre
en place il y a même B6 échec pour
l'instant fourchette du coup il a pas
réussi à passer et c'est contenté du
demi-point ok on les a on les a à
l'écran les deux joueurs guérit n'a pas
l'air malheureux et on va pouvoir aller
voir Magnus est-ce que lui va réussir à
bien pousser cette finale là
et bien en tout cas tu sais quoi j'ai
pas osé proposer roi H2 tout à l'heure
parce que je croyais que tu allais mais
j'ai pensé à sur général je pensais que
c'était à coup utile tu vois et puis je
suis après après la petite fenêtre de
jouer moi je sentais que j'ai regardé
on peut avoir des remarques déjà
gratuites mais là c'était un peu
chercher quand même mais il y a eu un
rêve d'un meuf 3 ok qu'est-ce qu'il veut
faire le match du couloir et un ski
amusant enfin moi ça m'amuse mais ça va
amuser que moi je pense sur dame aussi
tu vois qui a l'air bien tu vois tu
protèges tout et tu empêche
ça et ça et là attention faire doutait
parce que si je perds mon pion B6 et je
vais franchement être déçu
donc du coup dans F3 c'est malin non il
faut que je joue un coup neutre
[Musique]
si j'avais fait une petite porte
j'aurais pas ces soucis là ah ben voilà
voilà tu vois tu critiques tu critiques
et après tu vois que la petite bague
forcément des accords hachis non non
on va faire un petit truc
je te dis à ma 8 pour 8 ce qui est bien
c'est que tu empêche B4 faut empêcher B4
sinon c'est embête
je comprends l'idée mais c'est vraiment
ça m'embêterait je comprends je
comprends
il a envie de travailler il prend du
temps pour trouver ses coups
ça va petite porte de petites machin le
petit truc en tout cas
il pose un problème juste sur la dame
l'ordi il dit 00 mais vous voyez qu'en
pratique un Magnus continue son 0-0 et
je pense qu'avec beaucoup de bonheur
presque et c'est difficile pour ça
ouais mais je crois qu'il est pas quand
même très content tu vois tu lui dis on
rejoue l'ouverture j'en joue une autre
il est ok quand même il a envie de plus
que ça c'est quand même pas assez il
s'est cassé quand même même s'il
réfléchit là tu vois déjà il a 20
minutes d'avance donc il a tout son
temps ouais c'est chaud il y a quand
même joué très rapidement l'ouverture et
que mon c'est pas tu as envie de faire
peur à Wassim voilà tu as envie de créer
une attaque de créer un truc de garder
les pièces ouais j'ai que de faire peur
c'est pas le genre de partie que
normalement wesh les perd on va voir on
va voir
alors quand j'ai un problème pour
l'instant j'arrive je suis obligé
mais tu peux c'est quoi l'autre coup
j'arrive pas à trouver alternatives pour
l'instant
est-ce que je vais te proposer un coup
très perle
mais si c'est trop moche
ouais d'accord la finale
j'ai déjà pensé non je me suis dit
qu'on a décrit tout à l'heure en mieux
pour les blancs le roi sort en plus par
un joint j'ai trois machins non je me
suis dit
par contre dames c'est 7 là je joue F4
maintenant je crois
mais même un roi G1 tu fais la petite
case mais le problème de la petite case
c'est vas-y vas-y montre dams et on
bouge les pièces ouais mais aujourd'hui
tout est permis ou est-ce que tu fais la
petite case
non pas encore mais tu vois c'est dans
l'air donc non bah de toute façon je
joue ça j'ai pas envie de jouer
qu'est-ce que je vais faire comme petit
clouage
du coup je fais l'attente aussi j'ai pas
me laisser de toute façon j'ai qu'à
faire pareil
voilà ça doit pas être si bête avec les
deux couleurs alors échec et je reviens
dans le C4
tu fais quoi maintenant bon tu veux
aller là
mais je pouvais prendre des cartes je
pensais et puis ça allait non mais en
fait je pouvais faire j'ai pas vu
peut-être dame C4 non moi j'aurais dû
jouer de lame de 6 ce sont pas trop le
choix
non non mais j'aime pas j'ai vu dame
Séville mais j'ai le droit de regarder
aussi que je menace des trucs aussi de
mon côté donc non non madame
bon c'est là que quand même là je peux
aussi
non là je suis plutôt pas mal j'espère
mince désolé pour les léger bug c'est
vrai qu'on a notre productrice qui a pas
internet archiable même si sur la
globalité du stream c'est quand même
très sympa
ça va voilà ouais mais tu as fait 8 ans
moi je me suis dit que tu allais
travailler avec ça
bon c'est pas encore fait parce que
je fasse des time
non mesdames B7 par exemple ok bon enfin
c'est quand même pas facile à jouer dans
ma vie
OK
on va voir on va voir peut-être une
autre partie plus marrante on a donc
ouais il va quand même étonné j'avais
pas en début de tournoi il avait il
avait deux victoires et pas de défaites
dans des style architectes mais depuis
qu'il attaque ou qui se fait attaquer
qu'il y a des positions plus compliquées
et bien il est beaucoup moins imprécier
dans je sais pas ce que tu en penses
mais là ça fait ça fait ça va faire la
troisième partie qui va perdre je pense
et qui va être il va même plus avoir 50
% et d'aller complications elle est
beaucoup moins d'impression ce qui est
assez rare pour le joueur de cet âge là
qui normalement
navigue dans les complications comme des
poissons dans l'eau et lui pas du tout
c'est l'inverse exactement
là ça se passe pas très bien merci Jane
pour le joli compliment sur mon pull
effectivement pull magnifique je pense
qu'il te plaît voilà j'ai même pas
remarqué et tu aimerais bien avoir le
même c'est vrai que
un très beau pull
c'est vrai que ton costume à côté c'est
dur de rivaliser malheureusement c'est
tu as essayé de mettre un costume mais
c'est pas suffisant quoi tu veux le voir
encore mieux
je peux faire ça je sais pas si ce sera
mais lève-toi bien brillant
je suis en filaire ah oui d'accord je
suis l'air donc je peux faire des
efforts
voilà
c'est ah bah c'est kubitch ma fille m'a
dit que c'était un ballon de basket mais
c'est un demi ballon de basket c'est une
marque en fait voilà voilà donc c'est
notre futur
c'est pas mal et il a dit ça peut
m'arriver en plus et puis Mélanie mais
là il fait froid en ce moment mais il
nous met Laurent il est en short il veut
pas il veut pas se montrer tu sais c'est
vrai que il y a moyen comme ça pendant
il est en pyjama
donc je vais vous faire moins fantasmer
je suis en jean voilà voilà dans le chat
je me demandais ce qui se passait sur
cahier des deux mais cahier des deux
c'est le seul piège de la position qui
est des deux dames 3 ah oui c'est
important on va le montrer ça Laurent
sur les petits pièges comme ça on a le
droit de bouger les pièces
voilà la double attaque mais ça marche
bien la double attaque faites attention
doublack ça marche très très bien ça
marche pas donc est pas possible
évidemment
mais on peut faire plein de coups ici
clairement
il faut pas faire Descartes non plus
qu'on a envie de faire un jour parce que
pour l'instant il faut prendre ces
quatre avec le rayon laser et le rayon
laser ça marche bien aussi on va
travailler on va on va s'enlever du
vis-à-vis non Laurent peut-être un petit
très tenté par roi cette maison je sais
pas si c'est bien
[Musique]
ah oui tout simplement
achète que tu voulais déjà faire tout à
l'heure
ça va nous forcer
un jouet fou G5
et là bon il y a une position qui est
très avantageuse pour les Noirs mais il
y a encore un peu de travail alors parce
qu'elle est un peu
atypique pas pas si facile pas très
tradition c'est effectivement le pion de
plus mais il y a du travail le roi noir
et pas tout à fait en sécurité donc on
peut toujours
est-ce que je prends du pion du pion F
pour essayer de te poser des problèmes
je crois pas que tu prennes si tu prends
des purées je vais tenter de prendre la
qualité quand même
il va falloir faire un truc un jour
comment on t'embrouille mais je crois
que
je crois que c'est dur parce que
je pense pas trop de problèmes pour
l'instant FG5 dame 5 étoile F4
j'aimerais bien faire tout ça mais ça
sera trop long
et mon fout pas jamais en fait ça le
drame donc sur Full ranger 5 je vais
plutôt
ouais alors je fais dc je sais pas
j'essaye je peux pas faire je peux pas
faire de la magie c'est pas moi qui ai
joué les cours avant
et du coup
même si je fais le tour des deux je sais
pas et il y a
Magnus noir demain alors dis-moi tourner
là je peux te dire
que je vais faire dame 5
a été sous-estimé
ouais faut que je fasse un peu attention
mais franchement ça a pas l'air tout ça
je fais tourner
c'est vrai que demain je crois que
Magnus double et blanc contre Paris
c'est pénible cette position
on a vu que c'était très dur voilà
mazout devrait la convertir clairement
prends ces cartes donc c'était un peu le
truc
ça va du pareil au même il y aura un
décès
et du coup on va retomber dans la même
position sauf qu'il y a peut-être
prendre de la dame mais c'est pareil
quoi enfin c'est horrible quoi
hello poignard hello à tous ceux qui
nous rejoignent je fais un petit tour là
sur les chats YouTube salut YouTube
mettez les pouces et abonnez-vous à la
chaîne n'hésitez pas allez-y
un pouce un pouce bleu c'est ça
qu'est-ce qu'on en pense de rapport on
pense que c'est ça qu'il est archi doué
évidemment on va aller voir rapport
alors et bonjour au chat de chaise 24
qui est qui est pas grand monde là mais
venez sur le sur le twitch c'est plus
simple comme ça ça fait un seul alors
cette chatte
il y a eu x 8 et c'est une position de
travail ici pour pour les blancs
tranquille kemmer il avance il a jamais
joué le 4e 6 il a travaillé
tranquillement sur cavalier fuite A5 il
a fini par craquer un petit peu rapport
parce que dans cette position il joue
cavalier fuite A5 ça fait peur ah son
idée c'est de revenir ok bizarre quand
même bien
noir en fait c'est ça le problème oui
c'est ça c'est dur donc le laisser
finalement
se faire du mal tout seul c'était une
bonne idée de la part de Kemer qui a
joué le coup très logique Cavalia 5 pas
très apprécié par par l'ordi on a vu la
jauge un peu
un peu bouger là-dessus alors qu'est-ce
qu'il aurait fallu jouer Laurent est-ce
qu'on pouvait continuer le pressing et
faire sourire un peu leur dos
ouais l'ordinateur je dis pas ça
regarde sur
E40
quand même c'est important je pense
donc je le joue hein parce que
la dame et maintenant tu dois trouver
une case
c'est pas mal
ce sont ces messages ou rien non en fait
tu me dis que c'est pas joli mais ce que
j'ai autre chose
j'espérais Adam Cécile soit j'ai au
minimum ton C1 ou alors dame B7 ce truc
qui m'embête c'est que je peux pas faire
que c'est 5 parce que tu as tout reprend
ses 5 madame c'est pour ça que je
voulais mettre pas n'est pas protégé en
B3
je sais pas oui
pion si tu le sauve mais c'est pas
impossible foutez captes tu vois avec la
classe c'est pas mal peut-être E5 quand
même j'aime pas faire franchement
mais bon je dors en retard
je vais te faire E5 parce que j'aime
bien E4 et E5 avec moi
tu aimes bien voilà j'aime bien ma fille
bien
on appelle ça jouer concret ça fait
plaisir
du coup ok bon en tout cas il a joué
Cavalia 5 et il y a eu ce cavalier BD5
c'est ça que tu aurais fait plaisir
cavalier prend des 5 faut prendre S5 bon
il y a quand même des problèmes dans
cette position les Blancs ont un
pressing long terme
[Musique]
extraordinaire il a failli jouer pour le
titre il a fait un tournoi fabuleux je
crois qu'il a terminé deuxième au
championnat du monde de partir rapide et
là il fait quand même un beau tournoi
alors il a pas il a pas beaucoup de
points entre guillemets mais bien sûr
sans qu'il mérite plus et on sent la
différence avec il y a 6 mois et voilà
la différence avec Yassine moi c'est qui
peut travailler les échecs à temps plein
et donc du coup évidemment pour le choc
j'ai vu aussi tu l'as peut-être vu à
l'écran que Jordan van forest eddingeren
avait fait nul Laurent alors quand il
est cavalier à 5 qui a validé 5 c'est
vrai que les deux pièces sont prises
alors on l'a pas
tu vois j'étais et du coup c'est la
partie avec fouger ses droits pour en G7
et on va avoir
sans doute dame prend B4 ouais mais
quand c'est sur une seule l comme ça
avant les deux pièces mineures c'est pas
un si gros avantage je pense ça gagne
pas quoi c'est mieux
non je crois que
j'en ai jamais eu entre guillemets
ok bon ça sera un pressing blanc sans
doute déjà je suis sûr
là c'est ma tour en l'air faut dégager
espion quand même pour pas s'embourber
ouais ça devrait quand même être
faisable est-ce que tu vois il y a
plusieurs
je te fais dames 5 échec tu vas faire
F6 demain
pas du tout appris à faire ça qu'est-ce
que c'est que ce truc si tu es pièce
loin dans tapes
si mais ça c'est les coups bistrot quoi
tu vois ça c'est tu mets tes pièces moi
pour Carole le mec quoi tu mets pas ça
pour stabiliser alors attends ça marche
ton histoire
donc toi mets-toi un tu vas faire quoi
ton C5
t'inquiète pas mais en fait mais en fait
tu m'as fait
un truc qui marche et franchement faut
faire gaffe la disposition des pièces il
y a du prévoir quelque chose
du coup qui a essayé tu mets un énorme
coup de frein tu fais Dame des quatre et
puis
je te dis est-ce qu'on fait est-ce qu'on
joue des 4 toi tu me réponds
explications après tu me fais croire que
j'ai oublié que j'avais proposé de me
décatis
non mais moi j'ai proposé dame Descartes
c'est le énorme c'est c'est je joue plus
pour gagner après mais qu'est-ce qu'il a
prévu je te propose ça je te propose ça
en mode coup de frein bah tant pis je
gagne demain quoi alors pour continuer
qu'est-ce qu'on fait concrètement ouais
peut-être Dame des 4 mais en fait on
fait nul quand même quoi c'est ça que tu
veux dire on n'est pas
mieux c'est sûr parce que le pion des
quatre est faible
et puis on a pas encore gagné à 6 la
disposition fait que oui le pion des
cartes ok je te fais voilà vas-y allez
tiens voilà
tu m'as dit qu'il fallait jouer agressif
c'est toi qui m'a dit ça ouais c'est
concret c'est concret
en plus c'est beaucoup mieux que demain
je retiens l'histoire des pièces noires
faut pas toujours le faire il y a des
contrées exemples il y a des
contre-exemples dans la règle mais non
toi c'est beaucoup ouais ça fait mal il
a joué quoi
tu me fais pas des sales coups comme ça
alors
quand même
non parce qu'au début et attends
t'imagines juste là tu me le donnes
juste avant que le mec le joue donc tu
vois il y a toujours un petit délai et
avant tu m'avais proposé l'histoire de
dame 5 Damas Damas en disant ça c'est
génial et j'ai gobé au début quoi donc
depuis
sympa tout à l'heure j'aurais pas trouvé
d'un mec par exemple donc j'aime bien
il prend l'eau on va aller voir c'est
terminé je pense on va voir la position
de prière il prend l'eau mais alors
comme rarement on aura vu quelqu'un
prend de l'eau
on va aller voir Magnus après peut-être
qu'il y a mis sa centralisé Saddam ça
dit pas d'aller voir à peu près
moi je regardais les petits messages de
de Vanessa à la Régie j'avais pas vu
qu'il y en avait eu autant je sais pas
si les a vu donc je réponds
et le petit Prague le protéger de
stouffe en difficulté
de programme de la journée il est
fatigué ouais mais c'est fatiguant c'est
tournant attention c'est pas en plus les
jeunes comme ça ils ont pas l'habitude
de jouer ce week-end c'est leur première
c'est la deuxième pour Prague mais ça
dure 13 rondes c'est pas des tournois
des des durées de tournoi auxquels ils
sont habitués
en plus un gros pion
le fou noir qui circule bien ton fond
blanc qui a plus de mal des faiblesses
encore sur l'échiquier
ça doit pas être vraiment pas terrible
ok donc il y a eu des coûts on reprend
un Shifu B3 tour C8 on travaille prise
B5 prise B5 tourner un des quatre
pour ces trois jouets ça commence à
s'enfoncer
c'est même les noirs qui ont
l'initiative bien sûr
l'initiative
tout de suite d'ailleurs tension
qui bloque et un moment vous poussez
votre centre pour gagner ce qui va se
passer vraisemblablement pour ne rien
arranger il y a le fou B3 qui est comme
on dit plus ou moins en l'air parce que
quand on fait des trois on peut pas
prendre parce que le Fou est le Fou est
en prise et il y a pas de cases pour ce
fou bref c'est c'est complètement
terminalo pour salut à toi pas de métal
bon match
ça reste le fil rouge
toujours c'est bien normal toujours et
puis prends pas trop de risques
c'est quand même une valeur sûre on a
bien vu ah très intéressant donc il y a
eu dame dessin OK et un concept dont on
n'avait pas parlé là il a joué dame 6
j'aime bien
on dirait que ça affaibli mais en fait
ça prend surtout la case du roi en D5 la
caisse d'accès et on va pouvoir ça fait
partie d'une barrière alors
effectivement ça peut paraître
affaiblissant comme ça mais c'est très
important on va bloquer sur casse
blanche le roi le roi blanc ça c'est un
super coup de la part de lait c'est
magnifique comme conception
je crois que c'est
maintenant on a trouvé un dispositif de
pièces la petite porte comment on fait
pour parce que là tu es obligé est-ce
que tu es obligé d'échanger non on n'est
jamais obligé mais bon
pas loin pas loin pas loin ça commence à
être un petit peu pénible en tout cas le
setup noir est quasi proche de la
perfection maintenant dans cette
position si on garde les dames j'en rêve
Dame des trois donc on peut être tenté
d'échanger mais je crois que la barrière
comme tu dis on a beaucoup parlé de
barrière dans cette dans cette partie
ben là c'est bon je pense pour
pour
aussi c'est je joue G4 mon cher Kevin
pourquoi je juge 4 parce que j'ai envie
de fixer pion à 7 B6 qui sont déjà fixés
à l'aile à l'eldame et j'ai envie de te
fixer maintenant j'ai cette H6 parce que
si les deux faiblesses
et je vois parce que si tu joues moi
j'ai trois j'ai l'impression que les
blancs vont jouer les Noirs vont jouer
H5 mais bon je peux me tromper et puis
on prend aussi s'il a pas du tout fait
ça il a fait rouge
en tout cas le concept de G4 que tu as
expliqué qu'il est quand même hyper
intéressant après
mais après on a quatre
je voulais faire un truc agroalfi G5
mais non c'est n'importe quoi touche pas
méfiant
non ok il décide que c'est pas toute
façon c'était pas très clairement non
plus et puis il y a peut-être un
problème aussi c'est peut-être que je
peux jouer quelque chose comme ça je
sais pas déjà après avoir bon toute
façon tu sais quoi j'ai le temps pour
faire il a fait roi G3 ouais 7 c'est la
partie il va faire au F4
je vois pas sinon quoi d'autre
bonjour
c'est normal c'est vrai que c'est plus
souple ce qu'il a joué un petit peu
Laurent peut-être que il envisage les
quatre mais il peut déjà placer son roi
voilà F4
mais est-ce que avec les noirs
j'avais peur au début j'ai eu peur de
laisser rentrer le roi mais c'est
n'importe quoi moi
ça c'est sûr que bah ça devient tempo
donc ça me vient ça me chatouillerait
ouais c'est rigolo
sur noir là-bas donc si je peux m'en
mettre sur blanc
je préfère
après je vais essayer quelque chose
comme ça il faudra que je réussisse et
que toi tu pourras avoir des
quand même ok bon ça doit être nul mais
c'est j'adore ce genre de fille
est-ce qu'on joue à 5 est-ce qu'on joue
pas le 5 si tu joues à 5 tu sais quoi ça
fait nul tu joues pas le 5 ça fait nul
quand même mais on a quand même on a
envie de se poser la question oui oui
c'est quasiment certain c'est comment en
fait comment la petite finesse qui va
permettre de ne pas
disons de ne pas avoir à résoudre des
problèmes plus tard tu vois parce que
plus tu te crées des problèmes plus tu
as de chances de te tromper et plus tu
poses des questions plus tu as des
chances que il répondent mal si tu poses
pas de question
vous dit parce que effectivement c'est
0-0 de partout quoi mais à force de
poser des petits problèmes le 0-0 peut
commencer donc le 0-0 le fait que ce
soit égal peut commencer à devenir un
peu critique et ça peut cracouiller donc
faut être encore précis là avec les
noirs pour pas se retrouver et voyez que
Marius il pose tous les petits problèmes
voilà il reste stable et il va le faire
suer
c'est ça exactement alors après c'est
vrai ils sont 29e coups on est on est
bientôt le contrôle de temps est-ce
qu'on a un truc à se mettre sous la dent
un truc sympa
ou les pièces volent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est tellement critique il y a eu dame
c'est trois Damas 2 ah bah il fait un
petit peu comme toi
un petit peu beaucoup ok ok
est-ce que ça te surprend ce que je te
quand je vois damma2 j'adore alors
maintenant non parce que je commence à
comprendre où j'ai atterri
mais en même temps mais c'est
intéressant parce que sur l'aspect final
on en a beaucoup aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
tous les jours il y en a on n'a pas de
partie très excitante aujourd'hui mais
je pense que c'est la venue de Laurent
qui a amené ça les joueurs ont décidé de
jouer un peu un peu modestement voilà et
ça lui fait plaisir vous avez vu hein
c'est dommage la seule partie un peu
chaude qu'on avait c'était pas contre
moi parce qu'il y a pas donné un
résultat si tu veux c'est vrai que
honnêtement il est attaqué de manière
modeste après c'est un super joueur mais
aujourd'hui c'était pas aujourd'hui sa
meilleure attaque c'était pas la peine
d'attaque il a il a deux pions de moins
il a pas fait un échec donc c'est un peu
triste hein quand même comme partie de
la part de Prague la fatigue la fatigue
attention juge pas c'est on juge pas un
joueur sur une droite
j'ai vécu franchement vous pouvez aller
comprenez plus ce qui se passe c'est tu
vois pas la lumière du jour pas par 10
jours non mais les 13 rondes déjà c'est
c'est des compétitions qui sont assez
marginales
à moi parce que je suis un ancêtre j'ai
joué à l'époque j'ai joué un national en
15 ronde ah oui oui c'était interminable
mais c'était pas mal enfin moi j'étais
jeune donc j'étais content parce que
j'apprenais évidemment je joue les
meilleurs gens français donc j'étais
j'étais fatigué on a demandé
[Musique]
oui bien sûr c'est fatiguant c'est ouais
c'est ça déjà que c'est long mais 13
rondes j'ai fait j'ai l'occasion de
faire une compète je crois du monde
junior ou franchement j'avais hyper bien
joué au début les deux dernières rondes
c'était l'horreur quoi enfin vraiment tu
as plus envie quoi mais ça dépend donc
ça ça veut dire qu'il y a beaucoup de
joueurs qui viennent beaucoup de parties
consécutives et donc certains qui en
perdent beaucoup aussi donc faut c'est
un autre c'est un autre genre de tournoi
qui est plus du tout habituel mais il
garde la tradition et ma foi bah ça
c'est quand même le tournoi traditionnel
par excellence c'est le seul qui a
résisté et après la cadence c'est en
font beaucoup 1h40 plus 40 minutes un
peu partout moi ça me ferait plaisir
parce que j'aime bien les tournois lents
là c'est on est sur du tournoi très lent
ouais mais c'est comme ça et puis ils
arrivent c'est comme ça et ils vont pas
changer à mon avis ils vont pas ils vont
pas raccourcir parce que c'est ils
tiennent leur tradition puis ils ont ce
sont quand même cette force ce talent
d'avoir des plateaux hyper intéressants
à chaque fois tu vois en fait je veux
dire il y a un joueur en plus qu'on
avait envie de voir c'était les raisins
bien certainement reçu la vitesse mais à
part ça tous les jeunes que tu en as
envie de voir ils sont là ah bah oui tu
as le tu as vraiment des stars du top 10
mondial et les futurs pépites quoi et on
devait voir Douda à la place de Maxou de
Lou hein Douda qui a qui était inscrit
et qui a non pas décliné à la
proposition c'est suite à des problèmes
perso qui qui s'est désister au dernier
moment ce qui a fait le bonheur de Max
the loup mais Douda ça aurait été encore
plus fort normalement que Max the blue
sur le papier en tout cas ouais bon
remplacement quand même de trouver ça en
une semaine de retrouver en remplaçant
comme maxout blue de la ancien quand
même champion du monde des moins de 20
ans
champion du monde junior et voilà le
numéro 1 iranien du coup mais il fait
partie évidemment de cette génération
avec Ali resa qui a permis à l'Iran
d'avoir il y a tabatabae dans le pays
maintenant c'est ça après ils auraient
trouvé relativement facilement parce que
si tabataba il y avait été été monté
c'était pas un mec ridicule du tout
c'est un top player et du coup ils ont
un gros quartier d'adresse donc ils ont
réussi à trouver
quasiment pied élevé mais c'est super
rapport pour mazout il a montré qu'il
avait qu'il avait sa place quand même
mine de rien
plusieurs années là c'était 14 pour le
dernier enfin ça a été que 11 à
l'arrivée mais cette année c'est encore
14 parties entre Yann et polyashi et il
manque Jules ouais Jules le problème
c'est qu'il a pas encore les lots pour
être qualifié au ah mais au B il y
aurait toute sa place et ça pourrait
être pas mal d'essayer de se qualifier
pour ce tournoi ah ça pourrait être un
bel objectif pour juger c'est dommage
d'ailleurs la vue ça moi ça progression
franchement il aurait été très bien dans
le B1 après un endroit c'est un endroit
dangereux pour je peux déprimer le
connaissant
c'est chaud il faut vraiment que ça se
passe bien qui perd pas une partie tu
vois parce que c'est un truc à tu peux
des c'est dur de garder quand même le
moral bien sûr les les trois semaines
donc voilà foyer avec vraiment
bien sûr je suis d'accord sinon c'est
dur d'aller faire les tournois comme ça
c'est trop dur et d'ailleurs Maxime je
pense que c'était mvl la dernière fois
c'était très mal passé j'avais
l'impression alors effectivement
c'était à l'époque elle a pandémie et
tout ça donc c'est vrai que c'est
embêtant parce que tu dois arriver une
semaine avant et tout ça tu as pas envie
de mettre quelqu'un d'autre dans ta
galère mais c'était mieux
en pleine pandémie tu as pas envie
d'aller là-bas
je comprends pas à parler joueur
en tout cas beau tableau de dressés par
Laurent on peut aller ah oui comme ça
pour les échecs que pour les échecs pour
les échecs à voir c'est un truc à voir
il y a comme l'Open à côté donc tu dois
voir
des échecs bon tu dois pouvoir en même
temps on a bien en France sur le tournoi
de la grande et puis bah c'était des
bons moments quoi mais c'est plus
provincial comme approche
sachant que c'est ça
[Musique]
pour ceux qui ont envie d'aller jouer ce
qui est bien et moi je trouve ça devrait
être plus fait en France c'est pas assez
fait je sais que c'est fait à Nancy
Stéphane ancien en tout cas une année
sur deux ou tu vois tu es assez tôt à
fermer tout le monde joue dans un tour à
fermer à 10 joueurs avec des gens du
même éloquois et tu montes tu descends
et tout ça ça crée un truc et surtout ça
fait au contraire de open un joueur qui
est par exemple à 1600 qui va perdre une
partie contre 1900 et qui va pré battre
1.300 là tu loues 9 parties contre des
joueurs à peu près de ton niveau à
chaque dizaines de points lourds près
c'est là où c'est le plus intéressant
évidemment
mais allez-y les tournois par groupe de
niveau ce sont démocratisés
[Musique]
des Open par groupe Elo alors ces open
de d'une quinzaine de personnes mais il
y en a c'est abcdf quelque chose comme
ça et du coup par groupe de niveau tu
vois comme quoi Laurent ils vont m'en
vouloir
ton idée est bonne ton idée est bonne
ton idée je pense que tu as inventé un
an ou non non
pas du tout pas du tout oh là là
en plus je connais j'ai déjà entendu
même si vous êtes pas breton pensez-y
parce que ce système suisse il a quand
même le ce gros défaut là de faire
l'ascenseur le yoyo on a tous fait une
fois dans notre vie donc voilà ces
petits tours à fermer avec cette petite
carotte tu sais à la fin où tu montes ou
tu vois en plus ça te c'est un incent à
venir l'année d'après tu vois parce que
tu es qualifié bien sûr bien sûr et tant
pis nous dit qu'il a déjà joué dans
l'eau
c'est épuisant par contre je crois que
c'est 5 rondes sur deux jours tu vois
c'est les tournois du week-end comme ça
il y en a plein mais après oui c'est
c'est dur c'est dur je vais réfléchir
moi j'ai joué en Bretagne une seule fois
je crois c'est un Guingamp le Top 16 ah
oui tu as joué ah oui d'accord ok on a
été reçu chez ben je parle pas c'était
club de foot là
je vous conseille
bah tu vois tu étais pas malheureux donc
si tu arrives quand passer des bonbons
entouré tu étais avec ton équipe tu
pourrais oui quoi s'il y a pas de raison
quoi allez on va voir Magnus pour y
avoir un jumelage d'ailleurs entre les
deux villes
je suis passé quatre fois trois semaines
quand même
je connais où il a joué le 5 échecs donc
prise de décision importante
et je bouge plus
fort
G6 donc il y aura un roi G5 et non enfin
tu fais quoi après d'accord je peux pas
bouger mais bon au même titre que 6
c'est trop pénible aussi et ouais donc
c'est super son système de défense là
c'est complètement nul
voilà la classe trop
forte de Wesley Sow qui avait les pièces
noires on le rappelle
et qui finalement
[Musique]
on attend bon ça va être
on le voit à l'image ouais c'est ça là
il a pas l'air inquiet du tout non il
est en contrôle
je t'avais dit le début il est hyper
important qu'on trouve parce qu'après il
lâche rien tu vois il joue très vite en
plus et plus que attention Magnus qui a
une 505 mais bon ça reste très facile à
jouer qui cherchait dernière chance 32e
coup mais ouais il devrait pas se passer
grand chose dans cette partie
gamer peut donc tenir en haleine pendant
un petit moment
alors que j'aime pas perdre et de retour
dans le chat et qui nous dit les gars il
y a un mec à l'image en veste grise
et t-shirt vert ça c'est important qui
vient de passer deux fois la table de
bouquet en tattant la poche intérieure
de sa veste c'est quoi un arbitre et ben
j'ai pas vu Laurent as-tu vu j'ai pas vu
mais
tu vois c'est de plus en plus année
Laurent tu vois
c'est tellement de mauvais goût que ça
ça doit être un orbite ouais je
plaisante
sans le vouloir
on t'excuse ce sera prêt pour voici
tellement sympa en plus ah ça aurait pu
être sûr que dans et d'ailleurs voilà
je suis désolé
j'ai un truc vert fluo c'est Wesley ah
désolé il stocke la poche
alors
si je prends
en 4 échecs
[Musique]
un peu bizarre ici Laurent il serait
presque dominé avec un cours au 3 on
voudrait faire un petit peu attention
exact mais bon ça a l'air de se
rapprocher d'annuler quand même
l'histoire on a toujours G6 qui a un
coup l'idée peut-être c'est de te
paralyser Laurent G6
C3 voilà et là tu serais gêné peut-être
B5 maintenant j'ai une menace
je crois aucune chance
c'est plus ça la position
j'arrive pas à te juguer loin de là non
plus tu peux toujours tenir comme ça
c'est ça
une fois que j'ai mon pied en B5 tu
prends simplement tu vas pas me laisser
prendre pour que j'ai éventuellement la
case ici ou un petit truc
le seul truc que je dois pas faire on va
le montrer c'est de faire web si
évidemment
je t'attendais là dessus Laurent
on voit que c'est c'est trop dur de
passer alors bon on attend la fin du
Drake Jessie jouer il a vraiment
l'intention de
de faire la barricade la forteresse pour
westso et on est tranquille
jouer
roi aussi jouer bientôt
il se concentre Wesley alors jamais
alors ça il faut prendre exemple sur ces
joueurs là regardez
une dizaine une quinzaine de secondes
pour être sûr pas faire de gaffe
calculer un peu B4 d'abord c'est ça
ouais
histoire 2 à 6
ah oui je peux pas faire B5 vous voyez
Laurent veut que je fasse B5 à prendre
cavalier des cartes il va me piquer et
B5 et tu vas piquer B6 on va quitter
mon ami dans pas longtemps on ira les
voir pour la fin du match on va aller
ça risque de terminer vraiment bientôt
petit tour rapide des sacs pour voir les
évolutions de partie donc Prague
toujours dans la difficulté mais Maxou
de l'eau à 5 minutes on est comme à
trois coups
de la fin de ce mini zeinte et
Lou il est en train de progresser de
manière intéressante oula attend très
joli des Français de et ouais qui laisse
ça devant l'emprise ma tension tout
reprend des menaces et si on fait tour
reprend des 8 d'abord il y aura toujours
des petits thèmes de c'est un DA mais ce
qu'on joue tout de suite faut faire
peut-être attention mais peut-être qu'on
peut jouer hein peut-être qu'on peut
jouer donc sûrement j'attaque ta dame en
plus du coup j'ai rangé cette sur toi je
suis
voilà bon Maxou de l'eau il a pas l'air
inquiet même si il a 5 minutes c'est des
joueurs qui sont ultra rapide et puis
bon il a finalement que trois coups à
jouer avec les Noirs petite partie de
Prague ça continue Kemer rapporte on est
là encore dans un mini Zina puisque ils
sont 34e coups
est-ce qu'il a réussi à stopper le pion
à pas encore
il va essayer de pousser hein ça peut ça
peut nous amener loin cette partie ouais
je pense que le déséquilibre matériel
peut nous amener vraiment une partie
assez longue
je rappelle que le record là de c'était
7h30 de stream Laurent avec avec stouf
et des fois ça peut être bâché en 5
heures ça dépend vraiment moi j'ai fait
j'ai fait long si j'ai fait les deux
premières rondes en anglais donc sur
chaise 24 et on a fait un stream très
long mais bon suite de l'heure il parle
tout le temps ça c'est l'avantage
énormément Peter Vina d'accord
ça va tu as le temps de faire des
petites pauses
mais
ouais ça avait duré il y avait un stream
qui avait duré très très longtemps je
comprends bien mais ouais il y a des
parties donc elle est partie
intéressante évidemment ah oui après
après des fois ça se gâte un peu il en
reste une c'est une vieille finale c'est
long c'est technique après les joueurs
sont très appliqués on l'a vu avec avec
Vincent Kemer plusieurs fois du coup on
peut aller voir Erika ici goukh
est-ce que les Noirs vont pouvoir
travailler cette position ce serait
étonnant quand même parce que
peut-être
pourquoi ce serait mieux
la tour passe et le ouf ou B7 le spot
mine de rien le roi un peu plus fort ok
bon après
je vois pas je vois pas notre résultat
mais bon on sait jamais
passer le matériel en général en ce
genre de choses
ouais merci beaucoup j'aime pas perdre
monsieur amis
ouais ça fait plaisir aussi ouais de
commenter en français évidemment on est
plus à l'aise normal surtout surtout toi
et plus à l'aise en français qu'en
anglais je pense qu'on peut le dire sans
crainte Laurent et d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça que je ne streamerai normalement
jamais en anglais à part pour un petit
plaisir pour faire plaisir aux gens quoi
tu vois à part une autre pour des vies
mondiale quoi tu vois
tout le monde sauf la Bretagne en fait
voilà exactement exactement où pour
faire plaisir ça c'est cadeau voilà
d'accord mais mais il y en a qui
aimerait un je peux te dire qu'il y en a
plusieurs tu vois Robinson je pense
qu'il aimerait Robinson
j'ai juste quand même assez coutumière
de des balles perdues
j'ai une grande renommée quand même donc
en équipe de France Jeunes quand on
était avec les entraîneurs dont un
certain JBM
les commandes quand on allait prendre
des cafés des machins il voulait tout le
temps que ce soit moi qui aille
et vous lis assister pour voir mon
niveau d'anglais quoi ils aimaient bien
c'est leur petit kiffe quoi voilà
effectivement Robin side ma maman est
prof d'anglais à la retraite du coup
depuis qu'elle est à la retraite moi je
me suis dit l'anglais c'est plus pour
moi alors qu'avant c'était incroyable
parce que j'arrive à faire mais bon j'ai
tout perdu j'ai tout perdu voilà voilà
il m'a surpris vas-y tu peux aller voir
s'il te plaît 30 secondes
mon cher Kevin
complètement si je me suis dit puis on
prend H4 c'est un dame et là j'ai foutu
en fait non
et ça le dernier piège ouais mais le
dernier piège
c'est quoi je peux même faire damocel je
crois
ça c'est peut-être pas mal aussi non
tu fais quoi sur la vaisselle
s'il te plaît
c'est joli
un coup de bol
qui reste une minute à Magnus mais bon
la position est tellement simple à jouer
donc et d'ailleurs c'est
pas tout à fait la partie
Magnus Magnus c'est ce qu'on va voir
Magnus allez un petit manus pour pour la
fin du Time Out et la fin de la partie
exactement donc réussi
trois à 6 F3
B5
et un petit G3 et là les deux joueurs
sont finalement en position d'attente on
a expliqué un qu'il y aurait
sans doute des thèmes à base de roi des
6 il va quand même essayer peut-être G4
parce que ça change quelque chose en
fait
oui pour faire agfg exact et créer un
pion passé éloigné c'est ma dernière
chance
donc là on fait G3 pour gagner un temps
pour voir
je fais G4 et tu peux pas si tu prends
prends tu as pas le temps de tu vois de
faire G5 un truc comme ça enfin j'ai H4
au prochain coup c'est intéressant quand
même malgré
les petits problèmes ouais mais c'est la
question de plus c'est incroyable
il est incroyable
et petit coup j'ai trois alors
effectivement à 56 secondes qu'est-ce
qu'il a joué P4
mais B4 ça veut dire qu'il lui prend V3
ok il a calculé sur foudé deux il y a
cahier des quatre et surtout B2 il y a
cavalier A5 donc ok il arrive je te
prends le pion V3 en fait tu prends
ok c'est la même musique ouais c'est
jamais
bien joué
tu es un peu tu serais pas un peu
un peu tu vois le cavalier peint un peu
dans les est-ce que j'ai le droit de
faire un 5
encore une faiblesse
ça me donne envie de faire cailler les
deux mais en fait tu vas peut-être
rester avec vous
et du coup non
je fais x 3 qu'est-ce qu'il a joué
ok parce que sur F4
ok juste je vais voir le petit
tendu c'est pas ça du tout cavalier
prend B3
tu voulais jouer quoi oui faut prendre
des cartes OK
on y est
j'avais l'idée à 5 mais c'est pas moi de
jouer
ah oui c'est pas toi de jouer
c'est ça
[Musique]
j'avais envie de le jouer au final